in this course you will improve your
javascript skills by building a shopping
cart in javascript with no frameworks
joy teaches this course
joy works at free code camp and he is
excellent at breaking down concepts for
beginners be sure to leave a comment
with something you learned in this
course hey guys joy here today we're
going to learn how to make a shopping
cart just using vanilla javascript so
guys this is a project that we're gonna
make today as you can see that this is a
clothing store and we have in total 12
items to sell every product card will
have an image a title some dummy
description price and these options so
what are these options these options
will help you to specify how much
quantity do you want of this specific
product let's say that you want 15
pieces of this specific product so
you're gonna increase the quantity here
by this look at this i'm making it 15 or
let's say that i want to decrease the
quantity i can decrease the quantity
here like this okay
so guys whatever product you select you
can always see the numbers updating here
itself let me show you a sample okay
let's say that i want to increase the
quantity of this t-shirt by six okay and
i want to increase the quantity of the
suit by seven then you can see that this
number is updating itself automatically
and do you see these numbers here four
five six seven what are these these are
your selections these are your data
even if you refresh the page this data
will not get erased how is this possible
in javascript there is a feature called
local storage through that feature you
can save all of your data inside the
browser by that even if you refresh the
page the data will never get erased so
we're gonna learn how to implement local
storage inside our project and guys look
at this if i click on this basket here
then you can see all of your
selected products that you selected from
the shop page
so here we're gonna get the thumbnail of
the product that we selected we can get
the quantity button here the unit price
is here along with that we have this
number so what is this actually so how
is this calculated this is calculated by
multiplying the unit price by the total
quantity which is 5 times 100 is 500
just like that all the cards will do all
of its calculations
and once all of these things are done
you can see the total bill here like
this let's say that you want to increase
the office shirt by 10 you can increase
it here like that and you can see that
this number updates itself and this
total bill also updates it itself you
can also decrease it like this there we
go and let's say that you don't want
this thing entirely so what you can do
is you can just click on this cross and
it's gonna remove itself automatically
like that so it's gonna work just like
that the source code of today's project
is in my github repository link will be
provided in the description down below
so once you enter the link you can see
that we have three branches in total
okay if i click on here then you can see
that we have the main branch product
images and the starter files so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna download
the starter files and start our project
the finalized project will be here on
the main and what are these product
images let me show you if i click on
here then you can find the all the 12
images here let me show you do you see
this one here we have all the product
images here and if i go back on the
data.js so what is this data.js it
carries all the data of our
product cards let me show you a sample
okay so if i go back to the store do you
see this data here yeah all of this data
are actually stored inside this data js
guys don't worry because along the video
i'm going to teach you how to utilize
this resources so let's start our main
tutorial
all right guys before starting the
tutorial first of all we need to set up
our environment to do that you're gonna
right click create a new folder okay and
then you can name it anything you wish
but for this tutorial i'm gonna name it
shopping cart okay shopping minus cart
something like this okay and then we're
gonna right click open with vs code okay
if you don't have this option don't
worry just come over to the search bar
and then you just hit vs code manually
so once it opens you're gonna come to
file open folder like this okay then
come over to your desktop and then
search for the folder that you created
which is this one shopping cart open
okay and then you can see your project
folder getting open in vs code the
source code of today's project is in my
github repository i'm gonna provide the
link of this repository in the
description down below so once you click
on the link you're gonna come over here
and you're gonna find all the files and
folders like look at this we have the
images folder here you see we need this
one for that you just click on the code
then download zip it's gonna get
downloaded in a zip format then you're
gonna open the zip like this then come
over to your desktop and then extract
the file like this look okay then we're
going to open this folder and this is
images here we're going to drag it
outside okay next up let's close this
one and then we get the images inside
our source folder like this by the way
guys this folder carries all the
solutions okay i don't need it but if
you want to keep it and if you want to
check it out sure no problem so i'm
gonna delete that all right guys let's
go back to our vs code here and you're
gonna see this images folder you see i'm
gonna open up this one initially you're
gonna get four images don't worry guys
i'm gonna add more images to this folder
but for now we're just gonna work with
four images let's open up this okay and
then you're gonna find pictures of
shirts t-shirts formal shirts etc okay
you also get a suit here by the way guys
you might have a question like where did
i get these images from okay i got it
from two websites first one is
unsplash.com another one is called
pixels.com okay so you just come over to
any website and then you right here
share okay enter then you're gonna find
images of shirts uh formal shirts casual
shirts pants shoes etc okay if you
scroll down then you see this image here
i took it from where unsplash.com so you
can find that that same image on the
folder you see so i really hope you
understood how i got these images from
and you can also use the same resources
to do your own personal projects okay
okay guys let's come back to our vs code
and now we're going to create three
files okay so first one will be
index.html okay index.html
then style.css
and finally main.js okay
there we go all right okay guys let's
come back to our index.html and make
boilerplate code to do that you're going
to hit excelentary sign then you're
going to find this option if you don't
find the option then do this you hit
control space together and then you're
going gonna find emmet here so if you
click on this one the boilerplate code
will be automatically generated this is
called emit plugin of vs code okay and
on the title we can write here clothing
store okay since this is a clothing
store website okay something like this
there we go one second okay perfect now
do you see the style css i'm gonna link
it here like this look l i n k
listen if you don't find this option
okay do this okay you're gonna hit
control space together like this and
then you're gonna find emit abbreviation
you just click on this one there we go
can you see that the code got
automatically written so you don't have
to write style css manually in the href
do these guys you just hit control space
together can you see this path here all
of them are automatically shown up here
you just click on style css there we go
i saved your time okay using emit so now
you're going to come here do you see
these two tags here ending tags you just
come here and write sc
again if you don't find the option like
this you just hit ctrl space together
and then you're gonna select this option
okay and on the source you're gonna come
here and then write control space okay
and then select this one do you see this
main.js click on it like this there we
go save it
next up come over to the body and let's
write some sample text okay so let's
write hello world something like this
there we go all right guys now we're
gonna use a plugin called live server if
you don't have it just come over here
and then right here live server
something like this let me zoom in
okay so do you see this one here live
server made by home with weekday just
come over here and then install the
thing
once you install the live server then
you're gonna come back to your html okay
and then you're gonna right click here
and then you're gonna find option called
open with live server okay by the way
there is also an alternative can you see
this one here on this ribbon this blue
color ribbon you also get the option
here it is called go live
if you click on this one then the
project will get opened in your
web browser something like this this is
hello world here let me zoom in in order
to zoom in you just hit ctrl and then
you scroll your mouse wheel like this
can you see this one you can just zoom
in and zoom out like this there we go
okay guys can you see this gap here okay
these are the default styles of your
browser so we need to remove those
default styles of the browser in order
to do that let's go back to your css
okay so you're gonna write a star curly
bracket okay m0 tab there we go this is
what this is emit then you're gonna hit
p zero tab there we go you see
next up you're gonna write here box
sizing border box something like this
save it let's look at the result can you
see that the gaps are gone okay and this
is font here we're gonna replace the
font family in order to replace the font
family just come over here and then
right body okay curly bracket now ff tab
now you're gonna remove this save and
write ss if you don't see the option
then do this you're gonna hit control
space sans save enter done okay save it
so that now let's look at the result can
you see that the font family of our
fonts changed
all right guys so far so good we're done
setting up our vs code project folder
now we're gonna start coding so the very
first thing that we're gonna build is
this nav bar this is nav bar here let's
build it up first of all okay to do that
let's come back to our vs code here okay
guys come over to your index html and
then scroll down to your body section
here let's remove the hello world we
don't need it we're gonna also use emit
here to write html markup quickly follow
along with me okay we're gonna hit dot
nav bar tab if you don't find the option
same solution just hit control space
together then you're gonna find the
option okay then hit tab there we go
that's how we're gonna save time using
which plugin the plugins name is called
emit okay you can see that emit
automatically wrote me a div with the
class name navbar brilliant okay guys
let's come inside the nav bar and now
we're gonna hit h2 tab there we go so
this will carry our brand logo name you
can write anything you wish but i'm
gonna write here clothing store okay
clothing
store there we go done so this is the
result so far we only have our brand
logo name here okay guys let's come back
to the finalized project do you see this
shopping cart icon here we're gonna make
this one at the same time do this dark
background color we're gonna apply this
dark background color to our nav bar as
well so let's come back to our vs code
here okay and below the h2 tag we're
gonna make another day with the class
name card look at this dot card tab
there we go now inside here we're gonna
have a icon and after the icon we're
gonna have another day with the class
name cart amount look at this dot cart
amount okay something like this there we
go and now inside here we're gonna write
zero okay so why did i actually write
the zero let me actually show you so if
you compare the thing with the finalized
project do you see this one here we have
a number here this is 47
initially there's gonna be zero that's
why i wrote the zero and for the icon
where will i get the icon from i'm gonna
use a website called
icons.getbootstrap.com
okay so if you come over here then if
you scroll down you're gonna find a tons
of icons here
so for our project we're gonna write
here cart
like this and now if you scroll down
you're gonna find a lot of options do
you see this one here we have a lot of
options so let's pick any one of them
but before picking any one of them just
scroll down and you're gonna find the
cdn can you see the cdn here just copy
the cdn okay now let's come back to our
uh index.html and then you just paste it
inside the head like this save it done
now we can freely use the cdn for icons
let's scroll up so i'm gonna use um i
don't know but let me just pick this one
or let's pick this one okay
now you're gonna scroll down and you're
gonna find this called icon font just
copy the thing let's go back to our vs
code and now do you see this one before
the cart amount this one okay just paste
the thing here save it done let's look
at the result okay so you have a let me
just zoom in a little bit do you see
this one here this is the brand logo
name this is our shopping cart icon and
this is our zero here all right so now
we're gonna style the thing and for the
color guys for the background color do
you see this dark background color where
did i get the color from let me show you
i got it from coolers dot co this is
this one here coolers dot co i got it
from here so how you're gonna use the
thing you just come over to explore
trending palettes like this okay
next up i just went to the search and
then i just picked on the black like
this then if you scroll down then you're
gonna find tons of color palettes i use
this color can you see this one here two
one two five two nine i used this one so
i'm just going to copy up this one and
then let's go back to our vs code guys
we're done writing the html markup for
our nav bar component okay so just copy
up the class name and let's go back to
our style css and at the bottom here you
just write dot paste curly bracket okay
so why did i write the dot because
if you come back to html do you see this
one here this is a class okay if the
thing is a class then you're gonna write
a dot but if it's an id as an example
let me just write here id okay nav bar
so if the thing is an id like this then
you have to select the thing by writing
a hashtag here hashtag nav bar then
curly racket so i really hope you
understood the difference between
selecting a id and class inside your css
okay let's remove that one let's come
back to our style css remove this one so
we're gonna keep a dot nav bar okay next
up we're gonna write here background
color okay easily write this bgc tab
there we go do you see that hashtag fff
let's remove that and paste the color
that we copied so i'm gonna write here
two one two
okay five to nine five two nine save it
let's look at the result so if you go
back here you see everything is
completely dark we can't see anything so
in order to see something let's go back
here and change the font color
okay so to to do that you just write
here color sorry color like this and
then right here white done let's look at
the result you see we have the result so
far
all right guys let's go back here and
apply some padding okay so p
tab so you're gonna write here 25 pixel
and then 60 pixel so why did i give two
values here let me explain the 25 pixel
you see this is the value for the top
and bottom and the 60 pixel is the value
for the left and right so padding top
and bottom will be how much 25 pixels
and padding left and right will be 60
pixels okay let me show you the result
you come back here so do you see this
value here this is how much this is 60
pixels here this is 25 pixel here 25
pixels here and there will be 60 pixels
here as well so i really hope you
understood how i applied the padding
okay all right guys our shopping cart
icon looks like this but we want it to
look like this can you see this one here
so let's go and style this thing okay so
let's go back to our vs code by the way
guys it's also a very good thing to
write comments so in order to write nice
comments on our code let me show you a
new thing okay you just come to the
extensions and write here better comment
okay better comment like this and now
you're gonna find this can you see this
one here better comment written by aaron
bond just click on this one and then
install the thing so let me show you the
cool feature of using this
extension okay so you can just write
beautiful colorful comments let me show
you so if you write slash star star
enter okay star and then star star slash
if you come here and if you write here
exclamatory sign then you can see that
your comment is now red color do you see
that so i'm just gonna use the plugin i
also recommend you use the same plugin
which is called better comment written
by aaron bond okay
so once you install a thing you just
come over here and let me show it to you
again you just right here slash star
star okay enter star and then star star
slash again okay so if you hit x limiter
sign like this it's gonna be in red
color and if you hit
question mark like this then it's gonna
be in blue color can you see that so you
have a lot of options so i'm gonna use
the red color okay something like this
and then here i'm gonna write changing
default styles of the browser okay
something like this all right and now
i'm gonna scroll down here in this
section i'm going to make another
comment so let me just copy this thing
from there and then put it here and then
here i'm going to write nav bar styles
are here okay nav bar styles are here
something like this there we go okay all
right guys our task right now is to make
the shopping cart icon with a number
indicator okay but look at our results
so far we have the icon and the number
here we want this thing to be on the
very right side how do we do it we do it
by using a property called flexbox okay
so let's go back to our html which is
actually here okay so here's the rule
the very first rule of
using flexbox is you have to use flexbox
inside the parent selector in our cases
look at this one can you see this one
here this is the main parent okay and
this one will be the children this is
also another children so how many
children do you have you have two
children inside this parent okay so
let's target this one inside css it is
already targeted here so just come here
and write df tab okay display flex next
up uh if you save it then you can see
some result look at this can you see
this one here previously this thing was
here okay now it's on the right side
that's because the moment you enable
display flex there's a default property
called uh flex direction okay so the
default value of this property is called
row that's why you saw this one okay can
you see that
but if you click if you come here and
then if you write a column like this
save it now look at the result can you
see that this was the previous behavior
but we want it to be in a in a format of
row okay so that's the result so far
okay guys i'm gonna keep it here and i'm
gonna code below okay there's another
property called justify content okay so
in order to put this thing and this
thing apart from each other we're gonna
use that justify content property follow
along with me jc js stands for justify
content sb means space between tab okay
save it there we go can you see that now
this is here and our icon is on the very
right side so far so good okay now we're
gonna style our icon here so let's get
started first of all let's go to our
html okay to inspect the uh structure
look at this okay guys this is our cart
here and inside this cart we have two
children okay this is the icon and this
one is the cart amount which indicates
how many things you have on your uh
basket it is zero at the moment okay so
we're gonna style this so let's just
copy this one come over to style css and
at the bottom here dot paste curly
bracket okay now we're gonna style this
element first things first let's set the
background color to white okay bgc tap
done okay and then we're gonna set the
color to black something like this look
not black actually did you remember that
we used this color from
dot co we're gonna use this color okay
done okay done now let's save this thing
and then let's look at the result okay
so guys look at this this is the result
so far let me just zoom in a little bit
okay so that you can see it better there
we go now listen guys the next thing
that we're going to do is we're gonna
increase the font size so that so that
it looks bigger even without uh zooming
in like this and then we're gonna apply
some padding and border radius let's go
so let's go back to our vs code okay and
then let's give a padding of five pixel
okay p five pixel tab done okay and then
increase the phone size to 30 pixel font
minus size how much 30 px done let's
look at the result okay there we go it
became bigger let me just zoom out like
this
up to 100 there we go it looks much
better okay so now we're gonna also
apply some border radius so that we can
make this this is corners here we want
to make this corners rounded okay let's
apply some border areas like this look
uh border radius border minus radius
okay how much four pixels there we go
save it let's look at the result yeah
there we go we have this result so far
all right guys do you see this zero here
i want to hang this here just like our
finalist project look at this can you
see this 47 here this is actually
hanging at the top right corner okay
we're gonna do the exact same styles on
this element as well okay so let's get
started so first of all let's go back to
our uh what's it called index html okay
and then we have to target that element
do you see this cart amount here so what
is this this is a class so we're gonna
copy this thing since it's a class so
you're gonna scroll down and then you're
gonna write here dot paste okay curly
bracket oh sorry curly record and the
very first thing that we're gonna do is
we're gonna increase the font size okay
font minus size one second font size
we're gonna set it to how much 16 pixel
you can use any value you like here but
i'm going to put it to 16 pixel next up
set the background color to red okay bgc
tab then you're right here red okay and
then set the color to white like this
white uh here is it okay save it let's
look at the results so far okay there we
go you see we have the zero here which
is white in color and it has a
background color of red all right now we
need to hang this on the top right
corner in order to do that we're going
to use a property called position
absolute look at this so i'm going to
come here and then i'm going to write
pos abs okay tap so position absolute
let's look at the result so we are going
to see this result so far now we need to
hang this on the top right corner in
order to do that look at this you just
come back here and then right top okay
zero and then you're right here right oh
sorry not inherit it's gonna be zero as
well save it let's look at the result
okay now you can notice something odd
the thing is kennedy is zero here it's
now on the very top right corner the
main reason for that is wherever you
apply this position absolute
by default
by default this body will have a
property called look at this position
relative something like this that's why
it behaves like this but we don't want
this thing to behave like this we want
the zero to be where we want the zero to
be exactly here okay just like our this
one just like the finalized project in
order to solve this look at this you
just come back to a vs code this is
property position relative you just cut
it okay
now scroll down uh this is card here you
just paste it here like this look
okay
now save it let's look at the result
uh here is it
there we go can you see that now it is
working perfectly fine so guys i really
hope you understood how the position
relative and the position absolute
properties work if you don't get it
don't worry i have an entire dedicated
video can you see this one here learn
css position property with examples you
can just view this video it is just only
almost 16 minutes long okay
all right guys now look at this
component here okay this zero is
actually inside we want it to be a
little bit outside at the same time
we're gonna apply some border radius and
padding as well so let's get started
okay okay guys let's go back to our vs
code and i'm gonna make it a little bit
smaller okay and then i'm gonna keep it
here i will do all the styles here on
the cart among okay okay guys what do i
want i want the zero to be a little bit
up and then on the right side in order
to do that i'm going to come here on the
top property remove the 0 and then write
minus 15 pixels like this save it then
you can see the zero going a little bit
up okay in the same way if you put here
positive value like this save it then
then the zero will go down okay so i
want this this thing to be in negative
value like this save it now you can see
that zero popping up at the same time
this is right okay i'm going to adjust
it as well to minus 10 pixel likely save
it then look at the result there you go
can you see that it is now shifting to
the right side next up guys let's apply
some border radius and padding as well
so p 3px tap okay now guys you can see
that the zero component became a little
bit bigger at the same time i'm gonna
apply border radius okay border sorry
uh border radius how much three pixel
okay save it there we go we have the
result so far now guys let's compare
this with our finalized project look at
this okay can you see that it is totally
identical
all right guys we have successfully
built up our navbar component now the
next thing that we're going to build is
these cards can you see these cards here
we're going to build these cards to hold
our image the title description price
and these buttons which will help us to
increase the quantity and decrease the
quantity as well so let's get started
okay guys you might have a question like
how did i make this card layout here
it's very simple i used css grid
property and then i made four columns
here okay in order to replicate the same
thing what we're gonna do right now is
we're gonna make a div and then we're
gonna put all the cards inside there let
me show you how i did the thing so
you're gonna go back to your vs code
inside html okay do you see this nav bar
it's complete we're gonna fold it how to
fold it put your mouse here okay then
you're gonna see a small chevron here
you just click on it and then you can
see that your code is folded perfect now
listen we're gonna make a day with a
class name shop like this look dot shop
at the same time we're gonna give it an
id as well hashtag shop tab the main
reason for putting both the class and
the id is that we're gonna target this
inside css and we're gonna target this
id inside javascript okay so far so so
far so good guys save the thing now
listen inside here uh one second let's
just look at the finalized project okay
uh where is it it's here so guys how
many cards can you see here one two
three four right so now look at this
let's just come back here and then let's
make four div with the class names item
look at this dot item star four tap
there we go okay now let's go back there
and let let's see what do we have first
of all we have image and then do you see
all the informations on this card we're
gonna make just one div and we're gonna
put all the new information inside there
so i'm gonna name this one image and
this one will be called details okay let
me show you how how you're gonna do the
thing so for now i will not touch this
three i will just work with this one
okay let's just first of all perfect
only one div okay and then we can just
perfect the other things by just copy
pasting the thing let me show you what i
mean by that
okay guys inside here i'm gonna write
img tab okay this will hold my image
don't write okay just do uh just put
your cursor inside the source and then
hit control space you're gonna see this
images enter and then we're gonna select
the image number one like this okay save
the thing let's look at the result okay
okay guys if you look at the result you
can see that the image is huge okay we
cannot work with this image in order to
make it smaller just follow along with
me okay just come over here on your
index.html okay this is image here just
right here width okay equal to double
quote just put 200 okay like this don't
put pixels just 200 as it is okay it's
still gonna work like a pixel don't
worry just save the thing let's look at
the result you see the image becomes
smaller perfect next up we're going to
put the details can i see these details
here so let's go and put those details
by coming to the html and below the
image we're going to make another div
with the class name dot details look at
this dot details tab there we go you see
okay guys inside this details we're
gonna have the title tag the description
let me show you what we're gonna have
first of all we're gonna have the title
tag the description the price and the
buttons okay let's make those things
let's just come over here and here
inside here you're gonna write h3 tab
okay we're gonna write here casual share
like this there we go now below this one
we're gonna make a p tag okay p tap then
you're gonna write lorem 7 or you can
just specify any word you like okay then
you're gonna hit tab like this there we
go okay now guys below this one we're
gonna have two things together okay let
me just show you one thing one second so
this is price and the buttons we're
gonna have a one div and inside that day
we're gonna have both the price and the
buttons let me show you what i mean by
that okay so you just come over here and
below the p tag look at this we're gonna
write here
dot price minus quantity okay something
like this there we go now inside here
look at this h2 tab here we're gonna
have the price okay dollar sign 45 okay
save it let's look at the result so
you're gonna see the 45 dollars here now
guys let's make the buttons okay so in
order to make the buttons look at this
below the price guys you're gonna make a
day with the class name buttons look at
this dot
b-u-t-t-o-n-s tab okay now guys inside
here we're gonna use bootstrap icons in
order to use bootstrap icons you just
come over here and then you can write
here
icons.getbootstrap.com okay this website
so guys we're going to use icons from
this website okay now you're going to
scroll down you're going to see a small
search bar here just come here and then
write plus okay now if you scroll down
then you're gonna see this plus another
thing that you're gonna see is plus lg
which is a large size okay guys if you
didn't include the cdn link just copy
the link okay then come over to your
html inside the head tag okay just come
here and if you didn't paste it before
just paste the thing like this okay and
then save it done now we can freely use
bootstrap icons into our project okay
let's come back here and with large you
see this one here i'm gonna open it in a
new tab and then i'm gonna copy the
thing okay let's go back to our vs code
scroll down and this is buttons here
inside here okay i'm gonna paste the
thing like this save it okay let's go
back and now i'm gonna get minus okay
like this m i n u s okay now you're
gonna see two dash this is a small one i
mean the standard one and this is the
large one okay so i'm gonna get this one
like this okay let's copy the thing
let's go back
there we go now before the plus i'm
gonna put the minus okay there we go
done now guys between these two icons
you're gonna have a div with the class
name quantity let me show you dot q u a
n t i t y tab okay now you're gonna play
zero here okay what's the reason for
putting a zero between these two icons
the main reason is look at this look at
this this is a plus icon right every
time you click on the plus this number
will increment at the same time if you
use i mean if you click on the minus
this number will decrement let me show
you a sample from the finalized project
okay look at this one do you see this
one this is the plus icon is the
quantity here and this is the minus
every time you click on this one the
quantity increases and it shows up here
every time you click on this one the
quantity decreases and it shows the
result here so guys i really hope that
you understood why i wrote these lines
okay all right guys with this our markup
is complete let's save the thing and
let's look at the result okay now this
is the result so far it looks like this
but don't worry guys we're gonna add
style so that it looks like this okay
the very first thing that i'm gonna use
is display grid and then we're gonna
make four columns how many columns are
here count with me one
two three four okay so let's go and make
four columns so in order to make that so
if you recall about flexbox if you want
to use flexbox you gotta apply that on
the parent
in our case look who is the pen if i
fold this one like this look at this
okay who is the parent of all the items
the shop is the parent of all the items
right now i'm gonna apply my display
grid where inside the shop okay this is
class here just copy the thing hi then
come over to your style css then scroll
down oh by the way guys i made a small
mistake do you see this one here i wrote
the font size two times okay just remove
one from here like this save it okay now
i'm gonna scroll down and make a comment
all right guys before coding first of
all let's make a comment here okay i
mean a better comment with some colors
okay in order to make it just write
slash star star enter star okay
exclamatory sign for red color or you
can use question mark for blue color i'm
gonna use red color okay exclamatory
sign then star star slash done so here
you're gonna write a comment shop items
styles are here okay shop
uh items
styles
are here there we go done okay now i'm
gonna hit dot paste
curly bracket now inside here i'm gonna
use the very first line is display great
look at this dg tab okay save it let's
look let's look at the result you're not
going to see any changes let me let's
see you see we don't have any changes
now we're going to
add more lines to it so that we can see
that changes so guys come over here and
then write gtc tab okay now guys one
second let's go back to the finalized
project so how many uh columns can you
see here four right and i specify 223
pixels of width for each and every one
of these columns i mean each and every
one of these cards we're going to do the
same thing look at this so you're going
to come here and then you're going to
write great template columns repeat okay
so how many columns do we need four you
write four comma so how much which
should each of these columns i mean card
should be 223 pixels so you're gonna
write it two to three px done okay save
the thing and now let's look at the
result so if you come over here can you
see that text were just outside now it
is inside okay it's like an invisible
wall here okay let me show you live one
second so i'm just gonna keep it here
and now look at this i'm gonna make a
comment like this okay save it now can
you see this text are actually outside
now if you put it here like this save it
now there we go now it feels like
there's an invisible wall actually that
space is getting divided okay all right
guys so far so good next up what we're
gonna do is do this border here black
color border we're gonna utilize that
black color border in our card okay so
let's go and make that okay so now let's
come back to your index html so we're
done setting up the shop now do this
item here just copy the item okay like
this let us come back to your style css
scroll down and below the shop okay
dot paste now curly record you're gonna
write here border all right border 2px
one second 2px solid you're gonna write
here hashtag do you remember the color
that we use from coolers.com use this
color okay save the thing let's look at
the result now can you see this thing
we have four
cards here okay card number one two
three four okay even though they don't
have data but still they're showing up
here the main reason for that is if you
come over here on the html do you see
how many div do we have here four divs
that's why four cards got generated here
okay so if you remove anything from here
like this
save the thing now look at that you see
the cards are gone but don't worry guys
we're gonna generate more cards okay
first of all let's perfect only one card
and then we can just copy paste the
other cards don't worry guys all right
guys can you see the image it looks
smaller compared to the card border okay
so let's fix that in order fix that just
come over to your index.html and then
you're going to open up the item do you
see this width here just it lasts 220
pixels like this save it now let's look
at the result there we go it looks
perfect now kennedy's edges it looks
sharp we're going to make border radius
okay so in order to root that come back
to your style css and on the item we're
gonna write here border radius four
pixel okay border there is it okay
border yes four pixels save the thing
let's look at the result there we go you
see now it's rounded all right guys look
at this can you see this nav bar and
this card they don't have there's no gap
between them let's put some gap okay
let's come back to your style css and um
this is nav bar just right here mb tab
and then 30 pixel like this okay save
the thing there we go done okay now guys
we're gonna generate three more cards so
that it looks like this okay so let's go
back to your index.html here now just
close the chevron like this copy the
thing
and then you paste it here then you
close the chevron
then do the same thing two more times
okay like this
all right then save the thing let's look
at the result okay now look at this guys
the details doesn't look perfect but
don't worry we're gonna style them okay
now how many cards do we have four cards
there is no gap in between them and it
is not on the center just like this one
in order to make those things what we're
going to do is we're going to go back to
our style css on the shop where's the
shop um here is it okay this is the shop
where you can write a gap 30 pixel
language look yeah 30 pixels save the
thing there we go can you see that we
have gap in between all the cuts at the
same time we want them to be on the
exact center in our in order to do that
just come back here and just write it
there's a property called justify
content jc and we want the thing to be
centered right so right jcc tab done
save it there we go so we have all the
cards on the exact center brilliant okay
guys now let's compare the thing with
our
final project look at this can you see
this one here we have a little bit of
padding here can you see this one here
but we don't have padding on our project
okay at the same time can you see this
gap here yeah they have a gap but we
don't have any gap between the title tag
and the paragraph tag at the same time
this price as well so let's make those
changes so in order to make those
changes come back to your style css and
then just come back to our index.html
okay
open up any one of them i'm gonna open
the first one okay now do you see this
details here copy the details huh come
back to your style css at the bottom
okay right dot paste curly bracket okay
the very first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to write display flex
tap there we go save the thing now can
you see this one here it looks odd it
looks like a format of row can you see
that but we don't want that because look
at the finalized project it is in a
format of column can you see that but it
is actually row so in order to fix that
i mean why does it happen that's because
there is a property called flex
direction one second flex minus
direction okay the default value of this
one is row every time you write display
flags this thing automatically gets
triggered okay in order to stop that
just write display flex direction and
then set it to column like this okay
save the thing there we go perfect
now guys next time let's apply some
padding okay p 10 pixel tap done there
we go you see this looks much better
than before and now can you see this tag
this is uh description and the price
let's put gap in between them in order
to put the gap between them just come
here and then right there's a property
called gap property okay gap 10 pixel
save there we go you see now we have gap
all right guys now let's compare the
thing with our final project there we go
you see the price is here and all the
buttons are here but look at our one
this is not perfect right so let's fix
that in order to fix that let's go back
to our html okay
now where is the price and the buttons
look at this this is my buttons here
and this is my price who is the parent
okay here's a question for you who is
the parent of this price tag and these
buttons it's very easy guys this one can
see this price quantity this is the
parent of both these two tags okay so
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna copy
this thing like this let's come back to
our style css at the bottom okay dot
paste curly bracket okay okay guys once
this is done inside here we're gonna
write display flex look at this df tap
okay if you save the thing now the
button was actually here now it behaves
like a format of row okay why did it
happen if you recall that i say that
there is a property called flex
direction and every time you write this
one the default property becomes flex
direction row something like this look
select one second flex direction row
okay save the thing you will see you
will see no changes because this is the
default property already but if you want
to change it just write column like this
save it you're gonna see different
result okay so for this tutorial i'm
gonna use row like this save the thing
there we go okay guys next up i want
them to be apart from each other okay in
order to do that just come here and then
write jc sb tab okay justify content
space between say the thing there we go
we have the results so far all right now
guys we're gonna style this icons in
order to do that let's come back to our
html okay can you see these buttons here
yeah this is the main parent right now
and these are all the chillers okay how
many children do the
does the button have three children's
okay so now let's
copy this one let's come back here and
now scroll down dot paste okay curly
bracket now guys if you
guessed that i'm gonna use display flex
you are correct i'm gonna use display
flex now look at this in which format is
it in in the format of column okay we
want them to be in a row just like this
one look at this it is a row format okay
in order to do that just come back here
and then write df tab okay what's the
default property of flex direction here
row okay save the thing there we go you
see now even if you don't write the
display uh sorry the flex direction here
no problem okay but if you wish then you
can write here no problem okay so right
let's write here flex direction like
this
put it to row okay there we go done now
guys we need a little bit of gap in
order to put some gap just right here
gap
eight pixel okay save the thing there we
go we got some gap okay now if you want
to set some font size optionally you can
do that as well so let's say that font
size like this let's say 16 pixel okay
there we go save the thing okay we you
will see no changes because guys this is
the default property already okay if you
let's say right here 26 pixel like this
save the thing it's gonna go bigger you
see but for this tutorial i'm going to
keep it six little bit 16 pixels if you
want to make it bigger sure best of luck
okay now guys can you see this plus and
the minus if you notice this thing
inside the finalized project you can see
that this is green color and this is a
red color okay so in order to do the
exact same thing just come over to your
index.html okay do you see this b dash
minus lg this is the minus okay copy the
thing come over to your style css and at
the bottom just dot paste okay this is
what this is the minus right curly
bracket then right here color oh sorry
color
then you can write here red okay say the
thing there we go now your minus icon is
now red color let's make it green okay
in order to do the thing same process
just come back to your html copy this
thing okay let's come back to your style
css on the bottom right dot paste okay
curly bracket now again right here color
what was the color green
green there we go done okay let's look
at the result brilliant
okay guys let's draw an imaginative line
okay on the x-axis here okay if you draw
an imaginary line on the exact center
here like this look at this then you can
realize that this this is a button here
and use this price here they are not
aligned on the exact center okay let me
just show you
a sample okay if you see this line here
inside the price quantity select or just
comment the thing okay save the thing
now there you go can you see this thing
here they are not aligned on the exact
center now in order to save the in order
to solve this thing just come here and
then write a ic tab okay align item
center this thing works on the x-axis
and this one works on the y-axis okay
save the thing there we go problem
solved okay now you're gonna get this
code back like this okay save the thing
there you go perfect
okay guys let's come back to the
finalized project and then right click
inspect okay if you make the thing
smaller let me show you if you make this
thing smaller how many columns can you
see four right if you make it smaller
like this there we go now it becomes two
columns okay if you make it even further
then it's gonna become one column like
this there we go now this is called a
responsive website okay in order to
duplicate the exact same result what
you're going to do is you're going to
come back to your style css okay one
second where is the shop okay this is
the shop here below the shop we're going
to make two media query okay look at
this add the red media and then you can
write here max minus width okay so we're
gonna write here first breakpoint will
be 1000 pixels okay
then you're gonna add curly bracket
you're gonna write here dot shop curly
bracket okay inside here just copy the
thing
okay paste the thing here okay now what
do i want
the moment
the moment the screen hits 1000 pixel
i want the thing to be how many columns
just two columns okay just specify two
here done save the thing okay now let's
come back here on our result
right click inspect okay now let's make
it smaller like this there we go the
moment you what's the width right now 10
40 okay the moment you hit below 1000
look at this now it becomes two columns
from four columns okay now let's make it
even smaller it's not gonna work because
we didn't specify the media query let's
do that as well just copy the entire
thing okay
paste it here and here specify 500 pixel
like this okay and now here you're gonna
write one
now guys save the thing let's look at
the result okay make it below 500 pixel
okay i mean through looking here okay
something like this look there we go it
works perfectly fine okay all right guys
so far so good we have successfully
completed the html and the css part now
we're gonna start the javascript part
okay but before that guys look at this
one can you see these cards here these
cards have different data look at the
image okay they are different look at
the tags they're different the price is
different as well okay so how did i make
these cards i just did this look at this
so how did we do it look at this inside
this div with the class name shop we
just perfected one card and then we
copied and then pasted the thing now if
you want to replace the data let's say
that you want to replace the image then
you have to replace this uh tag let me
show you a sample okay so how do you
replace the thing like this look so
first of all you remove the image from
here and then control space you're gonna
select image number two then you're
gonna replace it with what office share
okay office shirt save the thing let's
look at the result and wait a second let
me just also clear this one and then
write 100 okay save the thing let's look
at the result guys there we go can you
see that now the data changed now how
many cards do you have you have how many
cards let's see four cards let's say
that we have 100 cards does that mean
that you're gonna manually do all the
things no guys obviously no don't do it
at the same time look at this most of
the data here most of the markup are
just copy paste which means
most of the things are repeating itself
again and again and again and again and
again right don't do this thing guys
don't copy and paste the thing here
in order to solve this issue we're gonna
use javascript okay so let's start the
javascript make sure guys you wrote this
line at the bottom okay otherwise
javascript will not work
okay the very first thing that we're
gonna do is we're gonna copy the id this
is id here so my main intention was i'm
gonna target this inside style css and
then i'm gonna target this inside id i
mean sorry inside the javascript okay so
let's copy this one let's go back to our
main.js and how do you actually target
an id
inside main.js look at this first of all
you're gonna write a variable okay let
anything you can write anything here so
i'm gonna write here let shop like this
look let's shop equal to you just write
here document huh oh sorry document
okay then what is this look at this it
is an id right so you're gonna write
here dot get element by id then you're
gonna write here bracket single quote or
double quote okay and then you're gonna
paste the thing look at look at this
there we go so now we have successfully
targeted our shop and we have also saved
that inside a variable okay now if you
want to test the thing how the thing
actually works just save it okay and
then at the bottom you can write a
console.log okay console.log and then
you just write your shop like this save
the thing let's look at the result okay
so now this is the result you hit f12 or
just right click click on the inspect
okay
now you're going to go to this console
here you see this so this entire html
element came inside the console if you
open up this one there we go can i see
this one here now if you select on this
one you can see that this thing gets
highlighted if you select this one the
thing gets highlighted okay
so we what did we do we got the entire
markup inside the console okay we don't
want to do that so what my main focus is
that i'm going to make a function here
okay and then i'm going to make the
function in a way that it prints me all
the cards automatically all right in
order to do that look at this guy look
at this guys what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna make a function look at this let
generate shop okay generate shop okay
it's gonna be a es6 arrow function so
you're gonna write here equal to sign
this will be your bracket equal to angle
bracket curly bracket this is called es6
arrow function and now guys let me show
you the regular function the regular
functions looks like this function okay
a b c d bracket curly racket this is
called a regular function this is called
es6 arrow function okay we're gonna use
this one all right guys now i'm gonna
remove the thing okay
now guys so how do we stop the
repetition actually first of all follow
along with me do you see these things
just how many things are here four items
are here right
let's just remove three of them like
this let's just keep one piece okay
let's just come back here and use this
uh function here let's trigger the
function like copy the thing and then
paste it here like this okay so we're
defining the function here and then
we're invoking it here okay and there's
this console here we don't need the
console okay save the thing now guys do
one thing inside here you're gonna write
a return statement okay return like this
now guys for sorry i made a mistake
return there we go now guys we're gonna
use template literal look at this guys
this is called a double quote this is
used to write strings we're not going to
use this no no guys we're going to use
backticks this is called backticks so
this is used to make template literals
if you don't find it you're going to
find this key below the exit key so look
at your keyboard there's something
called escape key i mean exit key okay
below that exit key you're gonna find
the back thing so you just click it one
time then you're gonna see the back t
okay so we're not gonna use this thing
we're gonna use backticks okay now guys
do this
inside here
uh one second you just come over to
index.html just cut the thing like this
ctrl x save the thing okay now let's
come back here like this now what you're
going to do is by the way guys one
second just look at the result
we are going to have nothing okay
now in order to see some result do this
just paste the thing like this okay save
the thing
okay guys now let's look at the result
okay we're still gonna see nothing why
is that that's because you didn't
specifically define that where this
thing should get printed okay you didn't
define the thing now we're gonna define
the thing so in order to define the
thing like where do you want to get
where do you want this thing to get
printed we want this thing to get
printed inside the shop because we have
defined the class
styles in such style css look at this we
already have the grid defined okay which
means that we want the card to get
generated inside here that's why i
selected the shop okay now let's follow
along with me just copy the shop like
this okay now come here paste the thing
then you're gonna write here dot inner
html and then you're gonna hit equal
loose sign done save the thing okay now
let's look at the result
there we go guys can you see this one
card here we have successfully generated
the card using what using javascript
okay now guys what we're gonna do is
look at this can you see these values
here these are called hard coded values
okay which means that we just use your
hand to write the thing now we're gonna
automate the thing how do you automate
the thing look at this first of all
you're gonna make a array here look at
this we're gonna write here let okay
shop items shop items
eq shop items data okay equal to you're
gonna make an array here like this okay
now guys let's say that we have how many
data do we have actually let's check we
have one two three four we have four
data right so in order to write the data
inside here look at this we're gonna use
curly bracket this is called object
which means that we are storing object
inside array so if we write one curly
bracket i mean if we write one object
which means that in our shop we have
only one thing to sell but if you hit
comma curly bracket and then if you do
it four times like this which means that
we have how many
items to sell for items to sell okay so
these are actually defined inside our
objects now look at this let's first of
all make the first object so how are you
gonna make the thing first of all you're
gonna set the id look at this id colon
double quote okay you can write anything
you wish no problem i won't mind just
write anything okay don't keep it blank
then you're gonna write a comma okay
then you're gonna put a name here oh by
the way guys one more thing this id do
you see this thing this should be unique
okay
and now on the name we're gonna write a
casual shirt okay casual shirt there we
go now you're gonna hit comma you're
gonna set the price okay so what i'm
doing is my main objective is do you see
all the data here like this one this one
this one i'm just storing them here okay
so let's complete the thing so price is
gonna be 45 okay then comma d e s c
description okay you're going to set the
description too look at this double
double quotes lorem
seven or eight tab there we go okay
now below this one you're gonna get
image img colon double quote okay image
yes slash img minus one dot jpg okay so
to to not make any misspelling mistakes
just scroll down do you see this thing
here where is it uh this is image here
the source is already here just copy the
thing yeah and then put it here like
this that's how you
that's how you don't make any spelling
mistakes okay so look at this we have
successfully defined one item inside our
shop okay in the same way look at this
guys i'm gonna copy the thing okay and
then i'm gonna paste them inside here
like this okay look at this which means
that we have how many items we have four
items in our shop at the same time those
four items has this data okay now guys
as i told you the id should be unique
let's make it unique like let's write
anything okay
at the same time come here anything okay
no problem come here and then i'm going
to give it a random value like this
there we go done
now the second one will be official
let's write office shirt on the price
we're gonna set it to 100 okay and the
image just replace the one with two like
this there we go now the next one will
be our t-shirt okay
set the price to 25 like this and image
will be which one three okay scroll down
you're gonna set the image to four the
price will be uh 300 because it's a
men's suit okay men's let's remove this
thing and then right suit there we go
done save the thing okay
now if you go back to the result screen
you're not gonna and you're not you're
not gonna see any changes why is that
that's because you also have to define
the thing by using a map function okay
let me show you how the map function
actually works so what you're gonna do
first of all is
do you see this backtick here just
select it up to this backtick here do
you see this one here okay up to this
point now cut the thing okay
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
write here one second uh do you see this
thing shop items data scroll down and
you're gonna write it shop items data
here
shop there is it okay shop items data
like this now we're gonna use a map
function look at this dot map okay
here is it now guys look at this inside
this we're gonna write bracket okay
now put your mouse inside this bracket
we're gonna make a es6 arrow function
look at this
brackets okay equal to angle bracket and
then curly bracket there we go done now
guys we're gonna pass the argument here
okay you can write here anything you
wish no problem okay for but for this
tutorial i'm gonna make it very simple
i'm gonna write here x so why did i
write the x here the main reason is that
this is map function here the map
actually will target all the data one by
one okay
so which means that how many items are
here okay tell me how many items are
inside here four items four objects
which means that this map will run four
times okay but if you have 100 data
inside here which means that the map
will run 100 times okay and by writing
this x it means that
we're targeting all the items one by one
one piece at a time let me show you
don't worry okay so inside here we're
gonna write another return statement
look at this
uh sorry return like this okay now
whatever you have cut you just paste the
thing like this okay there we go save
the thing okay now let's look at the
result guys look at this
there we go can you see this one here
but guys guys one second it looks odd
okay look at this one can you see this
one and can you see this one here it
looks odd that's because can you see
this invisible comma here i can already
see it here can you see this comma yeah
it's coming okay so we have to remove
this comma only then we can see the
specific result in order to remove that
comma all right guys come back to your
main.js and then you're gonna scroll
down okay do you see this ending curly
bracket before this one okay do you see
this one here just before this one right
dot join okay
bracket then double quote okay done save
the thing let's look at the result there
we go the comma are gone but guys look
at this the data did not get changed
okay but we want them to get changed
automatically how do we want the thing
we want the thing to get changed
automatically in order to do that it's
very simple guys look at this do you
remember the x that i wrote you see it
means that we are targeting all of them
one by one one by one so how many times
uh the map will run first of all tell me
how many data we have we have four data
so the map will run one by one uh i mean
sorry the map will run four times and
all of them will run one by one so now
look at this this is x here let's just
come here and use this casual shirt
remove the casual shirt like this okay
now you're gonna write here dollar sign
curly bracket then you're gonna say x
dot why did i write the dot because it
is actually an object so what did you
specify here this is an object right
that's why the x is object now look at
this this is name here just copy the
name okay scroll down and do you see
this one here just paste the thing like
this there we go done save the thing now
let's look at the result okay
uh if you see this name then you're
gonna see that the tags got changed look
at this this is casual shirt this is
office shirt this is t-shirt this is
men's suit okay but the image didn't get
changed look at this we're gonna do the
same thing for the price look at this
it's very simple look at this remove the
45 but you don't remove this dollar sign
okay hit a space now right dollar sign
curly bracket x dot uh what was it price
right p r i if you are not sure about
spell if you're not sure about the
spelling just come here okay copy the
spelling
scroll down paste the thing here like
this then save the thing okay now let's
look at the result you see
that price also got changed you see that
brilliant now guys look at this can you
see this every time you have to use the
x you gotta write x dot x dot x dot
that's annoying right so in order to
prevent that we're gonna use something
called d structuring okay it's very fun
to use look at this so look
look at this how many things do we have
inside the object we have image we have
name price description image okay so now
in order to use all of them load this
i'm gonna destructure the thing okay so
come here and then you're gonna write
here let okay or not here sorry guys my
bad it should be actually inside here
this is map here it should be inside the
map okay so you can right here let curly
bracket equal to x okay now do you see
these things here just copy them one by
one okay copy them put it here
and then you're gonna hit comma all
right now let's get the name
paste the thing here get the price
and also make sure to put a comma page
the thing okay then lastly we have the
description in the image so comma dsc
comma img save the thing there we go now
guys you don't have to write the x dot
anymore okay so let's let's remove the
thing like this
okay let's remove the thing from here as
well there we go let's look at the
result so we got the exact same result
okay by writing
this line of code and also doing these
changes by the way guys why do we write
x dot x dot x dot here's a question you
might have a question right so what is
this this is an object right so in order
to access the object we write it like
this look abc dot oh sorry oh sorry what
was the name of the thing
uh shop items data right so let's copy
the thing so let's assume the thing is
object okay if you want to
if you want to access the price you just
write the object name and then you have
to write the dot price like this okay
that's why guys we had to write the x
dot name because the thing is object
okay because we specified the thing here
as an object okay i really hope that you
understood up to this point and
everything okay now guys i'm gonna
remove the thing and then i'm gonna save
it okay now guys do you see this um
where's the image here's the image right
copy the thing remove it from here okay
source equal to dollar sign curly
bracket paste the thing done save it
let's look at the result
there we go can you see that now we have
different images it looks just like our
finalized project can you see that
brilliant guys next up this is
description here yeah we're gonna change
the description in order to do that uh
we're gonna come back here and uh we're
gonna remove this one
okay
next up right dollar sign curly bracket
oh sorry curly record and then you're
gonna write here description d e s c
done let's look at the result there we
go guys okay we are successful up to
this point and everything okay
all right guys if you notice carefully
then you can see that we use the image
description price and the name but we
didn't use the id okay we're gonna use
the id inside the parent okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna write id
so we're gonna write here id okay equal
to we're gonna write here product okay
minus id minus dollar sign curly bracket
id save the thing now let's look at the
result okay so you're gonna come here
and then you're gonna right click
inspect okay now you're gonna go to your
elements and then open the shop here's
the shop okay now this is how many cars
do you have four one two three four now
you can notice that all of these cards
got itself id which is actually unique
can you see this one here this is a
unique id unique id unique id etc i
really hope that you understood up to
this point and everything okay at the
same time guys let's come back here and
you just copy the id from here scroll
down do you see this quantity here yeah
we're gonna put a id here as well look
at this id equal to dollars and curly
bracket pays a thing okay the main
reason for putting this thing here is
that guys this is zero here yeah every
time we increment the thing we're gonna
target the id and then we're gonna
increment the number at the same time
every time you decrement the thing we're
gonna target this one and then we're
gonna decrement the thing don't worry
guys we're gonna make this function
right now so that you can have a
practical feel of how the thing actually
works okay
all right guys so far so good now we're
gonna make two functions the increment
and the decrement function my main
objective is that every time you click
on the plus the number will increase
okay at the same time every time you
click on this one the decrement the
number will change as well so we're
gonna make two functions this will be
increment this will be decrement okay
and do you see this one here we're gonna
make another function which will be
called update which will which has only
one function to update the number okay
so let's get started okay so let's come
back to our all right guys let's go back
to our vs code inside the main.js okay
do you see this data here it's huge
right we can fold this how do you fold
this just come here click on the share
okay done now it's more manageable okay
now below this function what we're gonna
write is two functions okay we're gonna
make two functions increment decrement
okay another function that we're gonna
make is called update look at this
follow along with me let is gonna be es6
error function okay increment okay
equal to this one arrow function here
like this there we go done now this is
responsible for increasing the number
where is it this one okay and we're
gonna make another function we should be
called decrement okay copy paste decree
meant there we go okay another one will
be called
update something like this look
there we go done okay now let me explain
again the increment is
responsible for increasing the number
decrement is responsible for decreasing
the number and the update is responsible
for updating this number here okay so
far so good guys so guys i really hope
that you understood why i wrote three
functions okay let's go back to our
functions all right now guys do you see
this icon here yeah and this is icon
here so you're gonna come here and then
you're gonna write on click okay
everything will be in small letter okay
on click
on cl ick okay equal to double quote
okay now look at this this is the minus
right every time you hit the minus which
one should trigger this decrement should
trigger right just copy the thing huh
and then come back here and then page a
thing like this okay now bracket there
we go done at the same time to use
increment here you can right here on
click okay on click equal to double
quote okay now scroll down and use this
uh increment here copy the thing scroll
up and now put it here like this bracket
done now how do you test whether the
thing actually works or not let me show
you just come over here and then you go
right here console yeah dot log
okay you're gonna hit increment
there we go and now let's come back here
and then write console log okay dot log
decrement okay decrement there we go now
let's test the thing okay let's come
back to here uh on the result screen and
then we're gonna hit right click inspect
okay
now let's come to your console and now
let's click on the plus like this there
we go can i see this one here it's now
increment okay now let's click on the
minus that's decrement there we go okay
so all the buttons are working let's
test all of them okay there we go okay
decrement increment so it's working
perfectly fine okay guys here's the
question how do you exactly know that
which card you're selecting
okay i can say that hey this is the
formal shirt one i'm selecting this one
you can visually see that but javascript
javascript doesn't have any eyes how
will it know that you're selecting
exactly this one right here is the
question so how do you exactly solve
that it's very simple look at this just
come over here and do you remember this
id here yeah this is a unique what is
this this is unique using this id
javascript can pinpoint which shop item
you're specifically selecting okay
that's why i wrote here id and i gave it
unique id for all the things so that
javascript can identify which item we
are selecting okay now in order to in
order to do the same thing here look at
this this is incremental decrement we're
gonna pass the argument here how do you
pass argument look at this you're gonna
write here dollar sign curly record id
okay in the same way you just come here
right dollar sign curly bracket id done
okay now listen guys scroll down here
and instead of the increment you write
here id okay save the thing let's test
let's come back here
f12 okay
open the dev tools and click on the plus
now guys you're gonna see a error id is
not defined that's because every time
you pass argument inside here you also
have to define that inside here as well
something like this look this is our
argument okay save the thing now let's
look at the result okay now it's gonna
work there we go okay click on the plus
it's working perfectly fine now can you
see this one here what did it give us it
returned us the quantity which is
actually zero and now guys look at this
juices id here yeah it is unique let's
click something else like this there we
go you see this id is unique using this
id we're gonna tell javascript that hey
we are selecting this
card here just decrement the number here
or increment the number here only here
don't touch other cards you got my point
okay guys we want only the id nothing
else so in order to do that just come
back here and now let me let's write a
variable okay let selected item okay
selected
item okay and then you're gonna pass the
id here like this there we go now copy
the thing put it here okay save the
thing let's look at the result okay so
guys now let's look at the result if you
click on here then you're gonna you're
not you're not gonna see any changes so
in order to see the changes look at this
let's come back here and on the selected
item just right here dot id okay dot id
save the thing now if you come back here
if you select on the plus like this
there we go you're gonna see the unique
only the unique id click on here this is
the unique id okay click here unique id
click here unique id done
in the same way guys let's come back
here yeah we're gonna pass the id here
okay we're gonna do the exact same thing
just copy both of these two lines yeah
and then paste it here like this there
we go done save the thing now look at
this every time whatever you click
whether it be the plus or the minus is
gonna specifically pinpoint to the
javascript that which
item you're exactly selecting okay so
far so good guys now listen the next
thing that we're going to build is we're
going to make a small basket okay look
at this i'm going to come here and then
i'm going to let okay basket
okay equal to is going to be a array
like this now what's the reason for
making the basket the main reason for
making the basket is that one thing let
me just fold this code okay like this
the main reason for writing the basket
here is that every time you select any
card okay what it's gonna do is gonna
store the data inside our basket to
still specifically which items did we
selected okay you got my point now let
me show you an example let's say that we
have selected this card okay so if you
select on the plus what will happen is
that look at this
here a object will be generated okay
inside this object we're gonna have two
items stored look at this we're gonna
write here id colon this will have the
unique id okay and then comma we're
going to have a item here where the
number will be just one which means that
we have this item inside our basket and
the quantity is just one piece okay
every time you click on the plus
something like this look every time i
click on the plus like this so what will
happen is this is 18 number 18 the
number 18 will get added here at the
same time so since you selected this
thing so this thing will be existing in
your basket by storing the id here let
me show you a live demo look at this
first of all i'm gonna remove the thing
okay i'm gonna keep it blank like this
look at this guys now i'm gonna scroll
down here inside the increment okay now
guys now guys inside the increment every
time when the user clicks on the
increment
this function will run which means that
look at this here i'm gonna write basket
okay
basket dot push so what will i push
inside here look at this
okay bracket curly bracket we're gonna
push two things first of all the id okay
so do you see this id here selected item
dot id copy the thing put it here like
this okay now we're gonna put here comma
now the next thing that we're going to
put is item okay colon now we're going
to put here 1 like this there we go save
the thing now listen next thing that
we're going to do is instead of
console.logging the id we're going to
consolidate the basket look at this bskt
okay save the thing guys now cut the
thing from here like this control x now
put it after the push like this okay
save the thing
let's come back here guys open the
console one second let's come here and
open the console okay look at this every
time you click on the plus look at this
you're gonna have one item inside your
basket this is your basket guys look at
this how many items do you have you have
just one okay now if you open up this
one you're gonna see that i you can see
that the id got stored and then the item
is one piece now guys look at this every
time you click on the plus you can see
the basket getting increased if you open
up this one look at this the same item
gets added again and again and again it
doesn't make any sense guys
instead of doing this thing what we're
gonna do is we're gonna increase the
item number here
if you click here three times the item
will get changed to three okay that's
our approach not this approach okay this
doesn't make any sense it is just
wasting our space here okay in order to
make the thing look at this let's just
come back to the main chest okay okay
guys inside here we're gonna make a
search function okay the main objective
of the search function is that it's
gonna search whether the thing actually
exists on the basket or not let me show
you okay so look at this one guys how
many items can you see here one two
three we have three identical items it
doesn't make any sense right so the
search function will search let's say
that you selected this one the search
function will search whether this thing
actually exists on the basket or not if
it exists
only the item will increase okay the
item will increase like one two three
four five etcetera okay but if it
doesn't exist then what will happen is
that which is push here it's gonna push
a new object inside our basket and then
we can see the option okay i really hope
that you understood my point of view
okay let's make the thing okay now look
at this you're gonna come here and then
you're gonna make a let search okay then
you're gonna write here equal to you're
gonna select the basket like this okay
basket dot fine okay one second so using
this fine we're gonna search whether the
thing whether the object actually exists
or not okay now inside here you're gonna
write here bracket
inside here you're gonna write es6 error
function something like this okay guys
now look at this we can write here x
you cannot hear anything you wish no
problem guys so for this tutorial i'm
just gonna pass x as an argument okay
the main reason for pass for the main
reason for passing this argument is that
is gonna check all the objects one by
one okay that's why i wrote this x now
inside here what i'm gonna do is i will
this is id here this is unique
okay so i will just search for ids
something like this look you're gonna
come here and then you're gonna write
your x dot id okay you're gonna hit
triple equal to sign next up do you see
this uh selected id yeah selected item
dot id copy the thing put it here like
this okay so what do i mean by this
it is just searching for one thing one
and only thing it is searching for the
item that you selected
and then we're just making a quick
search does the thing actually exist or
not next up guys look at this you're
gonna make an if else statement look at
this if huh
bracket
and then you're gonna right here search
if the search is undefined look at this
triple equal to sign and then you're
gonna write here undefined like this
okay guys what do i mean by this i mean
by this is that if we don't find the
thing that we're trying to search only
then we're gonna push the object inside
the basket so i'm gonna cut the thing
and then put it inside here okay
else
like else like what do i mean by else if
we find the thing okay then we're gonna
do this look else curly bracket you're
gonna write here search
uh this is search here copy the search
okay paste it here and then you're gonna
write here plus oh sorry guys we also
have to write the item dot item okay
plus equal to you're gonna write here
one done now now guys let's look at the
result let's come back here and now look
at this if i select the plus look at
this we're gonna see only one object
okay bear with me guys now guys let's
look at the logic okay look at this if
the thing doesn't exist only then push
the thing if it already exists just
increase the quantity okay so what will
happen in our in our case if i select on
the plus like this then what will happen
tell me guys
only the item will increase because we
already have the id so which function is
responsible for searching for the thing
the search is responsible for finding
the thing okay
let's come back here and now let's click
on the plus look at that let's open up
this one there we go guys we have the id
and the item increased let's increase it
again like this there we go let's open
up this one there we go you see item is
now three brilliant guys now let's click
on this one now guys one second how many
i how many object can you see inside
this area only one now guys tell me does
this thing exist inside the basket yes
or no it's a no so you're gonna click on
this you're gonna click on this now you
can see that we have two objects inside
here this is the first one this is the
second one and the item is only one
piece let's increase the thing like this
click on this one there we go the item
now increased so guys i really really
really hope that you understood how the
logic actually works okay
in the same way guys we're gonna make
the decrement function can you see this
one here we're gonna make the decrement
function so let's get started so guys
the decrement function is more or less
quite similar to the increment function
so follow along with me guys just copy
the entire thing like this okay like
this one second copy this and now come
over here and delete this thing okay
make it blank and then paste the thing
here all right now guys this is plus
here here we're gonna put a minus like
this look okay done okay guys after
putting the minus here let's look at the
result okay so you're gonna see the
result immediately now look at this i'm
gonna select here five time okay one two
three four five okay now let's open up
this one you can see the item five now
let's decrement the thing like this look
one two three now the item should be how
much two there we go it's working
perfectly fine guys now look at this i'm
gonna select it more times look at this
i'm just gonna click on the thing okay
now look at the result if i open the
very last one look at this now the item
is -10 it doesn't make any sense right
so what we're gonna do is we have to
stop this thing from going below zero in
order to do the thing follow along with
me guys just come over here and do this
if statement here yeah instead of the
undefined we can write here zero okay
now here is gonna be search dot item
which means that one second guys one
second let me just undo the things okay
one second where did i get the search
dot item you might have a question right
so we actually got it from here can you
see this one here id and then we have
something called item so the moment the
thing hits zero
okay bear with me guys the moment the
thing hits zero we're gonna stop the
process so that's why i wrote search dot
item equal to zero look at this search
dot item yeah instead of undefined is
gonna be zero like this there we go and
how do you stop the process look at this
do you see these things here just remove
the curly bracket like this okay
and now just right here return it's
gonna stop the process completely like
this your code should look something
like this now guys let's test the result
okay let's come back here on the results
screen and look at this i'm gonna select
this one two three
let's look at the result there we go the
item is now 3 let's decrement 1 2 let's
look at the result there we go the item
is 1. the moment you click it again look
at this it's going to become 0 right
which means that
if you click it again here look at this
even if you click on keep clicking the
thing look at this it's not working even
if i click it 100 times it's not working
why is that that's because i completely
stopped the process okay by writing this
statement the return statement means
that just stop the thing don't do
anything okay just like this so guys i
really really really really hope that
you understood up to this point and
everything okay so you can just pick any
card here just click on the thing and
then it's incrementing like this and if
you want to decrement just clip on keep
on decrementing the moment it hits zero
look at this the moment it hits zero
it's not gonna do anything anymore but
if you want to say let's say increment
the thing if you click on the plus now
it's gonna work look at that click on
the thing now there we go you see now
it's one piece okay
now guys the next thing that we're gonna
do is do you remember the update
function where's the update here's the
update function we're gonna define the
update function right now so that it
gives us 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 etc just like the
finalized project you see this one
keep on clicking you can see the result
live okay so let's do the same thing in
order to do the thing let's come back to
vs code scroll down you see the update
we're going to define the thing
so guys first things first
when do you want the update function to
run
we want the thing to run every time one
second we want the thing to run every
time we click on the plus or the minus
so let me just show you a sample what do
i mean by that okay so come here and
then we're gonna write a console okay
console.log
okay we're gonna write here the update
function
is running okay now since i told you
every time we click on the plus or the
minus we want the update to run so do
this okay just copy the update now
scroll up to your increment function
first of all okay do you see this one
here console.log basket before this one
just paste the thing like this okay
update bracket done now scroll down this
is decrement here after the console.log
page the thing bracket done save the
thing now look at the result guys let's
come back here open the console okay now
every time you click on the plus the
update function is running is working
perfectly fine look at this whatever you
click however you click the thing works
okay
all right guys instead of printing
console log we want to print the numbers
here okay in order to do that first of
all let's go back to our vs code okay
and now first of all let's define um
increment okay inside the increment do
you remember the unique id where's the
unique id here's the unique id okay just
copy the unique id guys scroll down this
is update paste it here okay
selected item then just pass the id like
this look select item dot id okay save
the thing now let's come inside here and
then just write a id here like this okay
save the thing now instead of just doing
the thing remove this thing and then
write id okay save the thing now
initially let's load the result okay so
instead of getting the update function
is running you're going to see the
unique id can you see that we're going
to get the unique id okay
now guys where will this unique id lead
us to let me show you the unique id has
attachment here if you open the generate
shop can you see this unique id here
yeah it has a direct attachment here
which means that we can use document dot
get 11 by id to replace this number
directly look at this i'm going to fold
this thing scroll down to our update
function do you see this one here first
of all guys we're gonna make a quick
search
if and only if the item exists only then
the number will increase okay guys we're
back to our vs code now look at this
we're gonna make a search function okay
let
search okay equal to look at this basket
okay dot
find
then you got right here bracket inside
here you can write es6 error function
okay similar process the way how i it's
a similar process guys the way how i
made this search i'm gonna do it in the
exact same process okay now this is the
way how i put the x here i'm gonna put
the x here as well okay now what am i
searching against i'm searching against
the id look at this i'm gonna write here
x dot id okay i'm gonna try to match
with this id if it matches
okay then we're gonna get some result
look at this okay after writing this
function look at this just copy the
search okay and then you put it here
like this there we go and this is basket
here comment the basket okay i mean the
consular comment the cons look here and
comment the console log here as well now
oh sorry not this one my bad it should
be this one okay comment the thing save
it let's look at the result okay guys
let's come back to the vs code and now
every time you click on the plus you're
gonna see a object on the console okay
where is this coming from look at this
it is coming from the update function
this is the console log is coming from
there okay now if you click on increment
in incrementing the thing can you see
the item getting
increased again and again and again
right so we only want the number we
don't want the id okay so how do we only
target the id in order to only target id
just come here and then write search dot
item done save it let's look at the
result every time you click on the plus
look at this only the number will
increment okay now we don't want this
thing to be here we want the thing to be
inside the zero here how do you do it
look at this just come back here and
then you simply write document okay dot
get element id and do you remember this
id yeah copy the thing and then put it
here like this okay then you can write
it dot inner html equal to search
dot item which is actually this one you
see this number i mean this is a
console.log it is printing number one
two three four five etc just copy the
thing and put it here like this done
guys look at this let's come back here
every time you click on the plus look at
this can you see the number it's live
it's working perfectly fine look at this
number is working how many items are
here eight how many items are here here
and here zero zero zero just increment
this one there we go guys it's working
perfectly fine at the same time guys
let's try to decrement the thing if you
click on here look at this it's not
working okay the decrement doesn't work
but the increment works okay
why is that that's because we need to
define the thing here as well there is
this update which is actually on the
decrement it's not defined we need to
define it just like the way we defined
it on the increment it's very simple
guys just copy the thing yeah
and then put it here and then put a dot
here like this dot id save the thing
let's look at the result there we go
okay let's increment this one one two
three four five six let's decrement
there we go guys it's working perfectly
fine you see
there we go guys brilliant okay now what
the next thing that i want is guys
every time you increment the thing okay
what will happen is this is numbers here
3 8 and 7 so what will happen is we're
going to add all the numbers together
and then we're going to display it on
here so since currently is what it is
zero so we're gonna add all the numbers
and then we're gonna put it here just
like this one look at this okay so if
you add all the numbers it's gonna be
23. you see if you decrement the thing
it's working here if you increment a
thing like this look it's working here
as well let's make that function guys so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna come
back here and use this unnecessary
comments you can delete it or you can
just keep it no problem okay
so at the very bottom you're gonna make
a
function you're gonna name the function
calculation look at this let oh sorry
let calculation
this will be es6 error function okay
something like this there we go
so guys what are we gonna do using this
function we're gonna add all the numbers
do you see these numbers here we're
gonna add all the numbers and we're
gonna display it where we're gonna
display it inside here okay okay guys
here's the question when and how should
the calculation function run if you
notice carefully guys so whatever you do
whether you do the plus or the minus the
update function runs every time right so
i want the thing i mean i want the
calculation function to run only when
the update function gets triggered okay
so in order to do this thing just copy
the thing okay and then trigger the
thing here like this there we go done so
listen so what will happen let me just
show you a sample okay so i'm right here
console.log okay console.log and then
here we're gonna write here
calculation accel uh collation
function
is running okay now save the thing now
listen every time the update function
gets triggered the calculation function
will get triggered as well something
like this look first of all this is
console log remove it or make a comment
okay save the thing now guys let's look
at the result okay let's come back here
open the console right click inspect
okay
now every time you click on the plus
look first of all let's go to the
console okay every time you click on the
plus or the minus look at this can you
see this one here the number is getting
updated one and then we're getting this
calculation function is running we're
getting this comment from where we're
getting it from the calculation function
which is this one okay which means that
this thing is working perfectly fine
okay now guys
we need to select this thing do you see
this zero one second do you see the zero
here we need to target the zero so how
do i target this look at this okay guys
let's go back to our index html here and
then open the nav bar so do you see this
here we have something called cart
amount okay it is a class we want it to
be an id so that we can easily target
that inside javascript just copy the
same thing yeah and then you put your id
equal to double quote okay now paste the
thing done okay guys now copy the thing
again let's come back to our main.js
okay now inside the calculation look at
this i'm gonna write here let him let
cart icon cart icon
equal to we're gonna write document oh
sorry document dot get element by id
bracket double quote paste done so what
we're doing is we're selecting our icon
here and then we're storing the
selection inside the variable so far so
good guys now instead of this one look
at this what i'm going to do i'm going
to write here cart icon
dot inner html equal to i'm gonna write
here 100 as an example guys look at this
okay so now if i open up the results can
look at this how much is this one it's
just zero look at this every time i
click on the plus it's now 100 but if i
click it again it's not gonna work okay
how do i make it work so look at this i
don't want it this is called hard coded
value i don't want this guys no no i
don't want this look at this i'm gonna
i'm gonna come here and then i'm gonna
here console.log okay
console.log okay
now inside here i'm going to write
basket okay ba s k e
save the thing let's go back here and
open the console like this okay
now look at this let's select this one
select this one okay select these things
and select this thing now if i open up
this basket look at this how many things
do i have here i have one two three four
i have four items in my basket do you
see the item guys look at this two four
three four what do i want i want to add
all the numbers
okay so in order to add all the numbers
what i'm gonna do right now is i'm gonna
select only the item
what i'm doing i'm gonna target only the
item not i don't need the id i'm gonna
return only the item how do i do this
look at this guys just come back here
and we're gonna use a map function look
at this basket right we're gonna say dot
map okay bracket we're gonna write here
an es6 error function like this now
we're gonna pass an argument x which
means that is gonna target all the
objects one by one how many objects do
we have here one two three four four
objects right the x will target all of
them one by one and it's gonna get only
the item look at this
so in order to specify only the item you
just write your x dot item okay item
done guys save it now let's look at the
result one second click on here okay
click on here like this
take this one take this one now guys can
you see this
we are only getting the number nothing
else okay we're getting only the number
this is three here the three is here
this is the four the four is here this
is five the five is here and the three
is here now guys we're gonna use a
reduce function to add all the numbers
follow along with me guys come back here
and now after um this one we're gonna
write here dot radius look at this r e d
u c e radius okay now right bracket so
you're gonna write here another es6
error function like this look huh and
now guys you're gonna pass two arguments
here one will be x another one we'll be
called y
so why did i write x and y the main
reason for writing the x and y is that x
and y
one of them is the previous number
and the other one is the next number
which means that one second so how does
the calculation work look at this first
of all let's consider the three as x
okay so that three what it will do is is
gonna add the three with four so how
much is three plus four is gonna be
seven okay so this will be the previous
number what's the next number of the
after seven it's three so seven plus
three how much ten okay so what's the
next number is five so uh say 10 plus
five is how much 15 that's how this
thing will run okay i really hope you
understood how the reduce function
should actually work now look at this
we're gonna write it x plus y now
optionally you're gonna put here comma
and then zero the zero means it is a
default number which means that we want
the calculation to start from zero okay
save the thing now guys let's look at
the result now let's come back here and
then write one two three four five can
you see this five here we have five
items now let's come here and then we
add three items one two three
three there we go can you see this eight
here five plus three how much eight the
calculation is working perfectly fine
let's add more things there we go let's
decrease something there we go it's
working perfectly fine guys but guys
we don't want the thing to be on the
console we want it to be here just like
our finalized project okay in order to
put the number here very simple guys
come back here use this cart icon here
yeah copy the thing
come back here paste the thing okay then
you got right here dot inner html equal
to do you use this console here yeah cut
the thing okay put it here and remove
the console from here like this there we
go guys done save it let's look at the
result
let's close this one now let's increase
the thing okay there we go you see seven
items here seven items here let's
increase it to three like this
ten items here let's try to decrement
the thing like this look at this there
we go you see it's working perfectly
fine guys okay so we are successful up
to this point and everything but guys
here's the thing this is number it's
seven it's one and one it's nine the
moment you refresh the thing all data
are gone can you see that but if you
look at the final project
look at this
even if you refresh the page it's not
going away
okay do you see this one here i'm
refreshing the thing again and again and
again it's not going away how is this
possible i am using something called
local storage
if we use local storage then we can save
this data look at this if i hit f12 and
if i go to this uh here there's
something called application okay now
one second guys let me zoom in this is
local storage there's something called
storage okay this is the built-in
storage of your chrome of your web
browser if you come over to storage on
the local storage you click on this one
and now look at this
all the data got stored inside here okay
even if you refresh nothing will happen
look at this can you see this one here
zero id is this one the item is five so
let's find that one which is actually
this one can you see this one here the
how many how many items are here there
are five items now if you make a minus
look at this
can you see that the number is changing
here if you increment the thing look at
this the item is getting updated at the
same time it is getting saved here as
well however you like you refresh the
thing it's still there it will never go
away because the thing is getting saved
in the local storage so guys we're gonna
implement the same functionalities in
our project right now so let's get
started okay guys after refreshing it
you can see a fresh instance of this app
okay every time you click on the plus
like this okay look at this now what do
i exactly want to save in the local
storage look at this okay we have a lot
of data here right i want specifically i
want to push the basket inside the local
situation okay so that the browser
remembers which item i picked up just
like this one you see so there's these
things here yeah these things are
actually where inside the basket okay
when i use the local stretch the basket
got saved inside there we're gonna use
the exact same principle right now okay
so when do you when do we want to
trigger the local stress listen every
time you click on the plus or the minus
we're gonna trigger the local stress
something like this look let's come back
here yeah now scroll down uh give me a
second where's the increment so guys
you're gonna come here on the increment
function okay here uh before the update
you can write here local stretch look at
this local storage dot if you hit dot
then you're gonna see a lot of functions
here you see get item set item remove
item clear okay we're gonna use set item
it is used to set the item inside the
local storage i mean setting data inside
the local storage and the get item is
used to get data from the local stretch
okay and the clear is used to delete
everything now let us see now look at
this inside the set item we're gonna
have two things look at this first of
all we're gonna have a double quote
now inside here you can give any name
you wish no problem but let's keep it
simple okay i'm gonna name it data
okay so this is actually the name that's
that gets saved in your local storage
let me show you so if you look at the
finalized project let's f12
and then go to the application this is
key here the data that's because i gave
it a name of data that's the key if you
write let's say your own name let's say
that i'm right here joy okay if i do
that what will happen is that the key
will get named joy and then all the
values will get saved here okay so guys
i really hope that you understood why i
wrote the
name here okay this is the key so i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna keep it simple
i'm gonna write here data like this
there we go now you're gonna put a comma
here and then you're gonna pass the
basket like this okay ba skt basket save
the thing let's look at the result guys
come back here and then
this is our uh project okay f12 to open
the dev tools and now go to the
application if you can't find it just
click on here and then you're gonna find
something called application okay now
next up we're gonna come to the storage
on the local storage open up this one
okay like this there you go can you see
this one here guys the data is the key
okay if you change the name just do it
like this look you just change the name
here okay that's the key and this is the
object that is getting stored okay look
at this the data is here i mean the key
is here and the value is here now if you
click on this one then you can see all
the details here currently there are no
properties now look at this if you click
on the plus look at this guys what is
getting stored something is getting
stored here we can't read it
so guys if you want to read the thing
what's exactly written here just like
this one just like this one so what
you're gonna do guys look at this follow
along with me there's something called
json.stringify okay just cut the thing
okay cut it you gotta hit json dot
stringify okay now bracket paste the
thing like this there you go save the
thing now let's look at the result uh
let's come here and now refresh the
thing okay so now just click on here and
then delete the thing okay now click on
the plus like this there we go okay we
got something here just click on this
one there we go you see the data got
saved here now look at this we have the
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
ten so you have 10 here the 10 is here
as well let's try to decrease the thing
if you decrease the thing you can see
the value is not getting updated why is
that that's because guys the local
stress exists only on the increment not
on the decrement to do that just copy
the thing yeah come here and put it
before the update okay
put it here like this there you go done
save the thing let's go back and now
look at this the local storage right now
is how much it's 10 right let's try to
decrement the thing
okay guys now let's test the result okay
first of all you're going to delete the
thing okay like this now let's try to
increment the thing there we go you see
you got you got a data click on this one
and then you're gonna find this okay now
let's try to increment the value look at
this click click click and then you can
see that the item gets incremented do
you want to recommend a thing sure why
not let's decrement a thing like this
there we go it is working perfectly fine
you see let's add something like this
let's add something like this like this
as well okay if you click on here then
you can see all the details here okay
guys we're successful up to this point
and everything now guys the moment you
one second look at this this is three
here and the eight here the moment you
refresh
everything goes away but still hey guys
look at this the data is still saved
here so our main task right now is
we have to retrieve the data from the
local source into our application okay
in order to do that it's very simple
just come over here so guys in order to
retrieve the data so what what are we
doing here we're just setting the item
inside the local storage now we're gonna
retrieve the data in order to retrieve
the data just come to the very top okay
do you see this basket here yeah we're
gonna remove the thing now in order to
get the thing from the local storage you
have to write json.parse okay
json.parse like this now you're gonna
actually have bracket now inside the
bracket you're gonna say local storage
okay local storage dot get item
previously it was set item now it is get
item now guys you're gonna have here a
bracket now guys you tell me what was
the name of the key that you gave the
name of the key is data right you're
gonna get the data here like this look
you're gonna write here double quote
okay you're gonna hit data now the data
will get retrieved and then guys we're
gonna write an or statement here okay or
and then we're gonna write here a empty
error like this so why did i write this
what's the reason for this okay look at
this guys so we have data inside our
local storage what do we have we already
have the data but what if we don't have
any data
what if we don't have any data then it's
gonna be error which means that it's
gonna break our application in order to
stop preventing from happening that what
we have to write is we're gonna give a
or statement and then we're gonna give
here an empty array which was previously
inside here do you remember how it was
like it was let basket equal to empty
array okay so if we have local data it's
gonna retrieve that if we don't have it
then it's gonna be only an empty array
so i really hope that you understood up
to this point and everything okay let's
save the thing
now guys let's come back to the result
screen and look at this it is zero here
and it is four on the local storage
right in the moment you hit only one
time it's gonna be five right now okay
this is the five here and this is the
five here now look at this if you
refresh it again it's gonna start from
zero if you click here one time is gonna
be six this is the behavior that we
don't want okay in order to prevent that
and in order to update all the things
all together what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go to your template do you
remember the template where is the
template here's the template okay just
open up this one now look at this guys
below this one we're gonna make a quick
search okay we're gonna write here let
okay search okay let me actually explain
why did i write this search and why i'm
making a search function here okay so
after saving the thing let's go look at
the result screen okay look at this so
what do i want look at this how many
objects are actually inside here two
objects okay the first one is six and
the second one is actually three and
other ones are actually zero okay so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
search specifically for the id
and the item if the id already exists on
the local stretch just get the six and
put the six here if it doesn't exist
then do nothing okay that's why i wrote
a search function here okay now let's
define the thing okay so you can write
here equal to then you're gonna write
here basket okay basket dot fine bracket
and then you got right here an arrow
function you're gonna pass here x okay
look at this x dot id so what we're
matching against we're matching against
the id so you're gonna write triple
equal to sign and then do you remember
this id here yeah just pass the id here
so it's gonna check for all the id one
by one okay guys now we can write an or
statement here look at this or
an empty array so what do i mean by that
i mean by that is that if we can find
something then store it here okay if we
don't find anything just return an empty
array okay so far so good guys all right
guys copy this search scroll down and
this is zero here remove the zero and
then you're gonna write here our dollar
sign curly bracket okay put the search
here okay so what do i want to search
tell me i want to search for the item
only i don't want the id so what i'm
gonna do look at this uh let me just go
back there and now i'm gonna write here
search dot item okay
like this okay if the search dot item is
equal to undefined which means that if
we don't find it then we're gonna only
return zero
but if we find it then we're going to
return search dot item something like
this there we go done save the thing
let's look at the result okay so this is
the result look at this automatically we
got the 603 even if you refresh the
thing look at this it still works can
you see that six is here three is here
let's put here five one two three four
five something like this refers the
thing there we go this five is still
already there but nothing is and now
nothing is getting deleted this is the
result that we exactly want and now guys
look at this even if we refresh the page
nothing goes away you just increment the
thing like this and then you decrement
the thing like this there we go nothing
is going away the only problem is with
this one look at this how much is this
12 right refresh the thing like this
it's it goes away to zero but if you
increase the thing look at this three
right increase it like this now it's
going to be 13. you see that's the only
issue that we have to fix very simple
guys the solution is very simple come
back to your main js scroll down and
then do you see this one here just copy
this one and then invoke it one time
like this done so what do i mean by this
i mean by this is that every time the
application loads this will run so which
means that it's gonna do a quick
calculation and then it's gonna print
the data here so look at this even if i
refresh the page look at this this the
13 still stays there let's try to
increment the number look at this 17
let's try to decrement the thing like
this or perhaps let's increment even
further it's 24 right now refresh the
page there we go done so far so good
guys we have successfully implemented
the local storage feature into our
application
all right guys before moving forward we
have some problem in our code which we
need to fix for an example look at this
if i put my mouse over here the cursor
doesn't change to pointer compared to
the finalized project look at this if i
put my mouse here the cursor change
changes to pointer okay in order to
solve the issue just come back to your
uh style css at the very top okay below
the body you're gonna write here i okay
so uh what i'm doing is i'm targeting
all the icon html elements okay and then
i'm setting to setting the property to
curb poi okay curve point tab cursor
pointer save the thing now let's look at
the result okay so every time you put
your mouse here the cursor changes to
pointer brilliant okay guys the next
problem is actually with the minus
button okay so the problem is the minus
button shows an error on the console
every time the local storage is blank
let me show you what i mean by that okay
so guys you're gonna right click you're
gonna hit inspect okay come over to your
local application local storage like
this now do this guys click on here
delete the entire thing so now refresh
the page go back to the console and now
click on the minus can you see that guys
we're having an error so guys why is
this happening let me show you so you're
going to go to your main.js on the
decrement function okay the error is
actually coming from here why is the
error coming let me tell you since guys
the local storage is blank which means
that the basket is also blank if the
basket is blank you cannot find anything
which means that eventually the search
will be undefined
and in order to handle the undefined we
don't have any if else statement right
so that's why the error is coming in
order to stop the error you're gonna
write another if statement here okay
then you're gonna hear search
equal to undefined okay then you're
gonna just return the thing so what do i
mean by this line i mean by this line is
that every time when the search is
undefined then do nothing okay now this
line will stop the process and guys do
you see the second line you just write
here else if okay something like this
else if and then save the thing done now
let's look at the error okay
so first of all make sure that your
local storage is blank okay now let's go
back to the console now click on the
minus there we go guys there is no error
right now brilliant now guys let's move
on to the third problem so in order to
demonstrate the third problem first of
all add something on your card okay add
something like this
okay
there we go now guys do this go to your
inspect and then go back to your local
storage like this
okay now what is this actually tell me
what is this this is our basket okay so
it's gonna show us which products we
selected along with the specific
quantity that we selected okay this is
what this is the quantity okay so as an
example let's say that i don't want
anything from here i don't want this
shirt zero quantity let's make it zero
like this so i made it zero which means
that i remove the thing from my basket
even though you can see a zero you can
see some data here that is getting
stored okay so guys there's no point in
keeping something on the basket which
has a quantity of zero it doesn't make
any sense so we need to remove this line
okay which line we have to remove this
zero so guys in order to do that just
come back to your vs code on the
decrement function okay guys come back
to the main.js on the decrement function
okay follow along with me guys look at
this what i'm doing i'm gonna write here
basket okay equal to i'm gonna write the
basket again and then i'm gonna use the
filter function look at this i'm gonna
write here dot filter okay
something like this now you're gonna
actually have bracket inside here you
can write an es6 error function like
this okay and inside the argument you
can pass anything you wish no problem
but for this tutorial let's make it
simple i'm gonna pass here x okay now
what are we filtering against look at
this we are filtering against the item
right so now we're gonna select the x
dot item like this don't worry guys let
me i'm gonna explain this first of all
let's write the entire statement okay so
x dot item okay not equal to zero okay
guys now let me explain the meaning of
the statement this is basket here what
is this and what does it actually carry
let's keep it side by side with our
local storage and vs code okay the
basket on the local storage is actually
a array okay inside this area it carries
all the products that we selected from
the store right and next up we have
applied a filter function here so what
do i mean by this x of the filter
function
do is this here we have how many objects
here we have four objects one two three
four so through the x of the filter
function i mean that target all of these
objects one by one one by one okay
next up what we're checking is against
the item so look at this individual
object here how many things can you see
here we have two things id and the item
we don't need the id we only need to
check the item okay
so that's why i have written this x dot
item and what do i mean this entire line
x dot item is not equal to zero through
this i mean that we're gonna select all
the objects which which doesn't have a
zero on the item so guys you tell me how
many objects
do we have on which the item is zero
only one object which has a item of zero
which means that
this filter will remove this object and
then it's gonna return the other things
so guys once the filter function returns
the filter data what we're doing next is
that we're setting we're setting the
data back to the basket so guys do you
see this line here we're gonna cut the
thing and then we're gonna put it at the
bottom like this okay so why did i do
such a thing that's because do you know
the mechanics of javascript javascript
runs from the top to the bottom like
this
okay
now guys let's analyze our code what are
we doing using these lines
using these lines we're manipulating i
mean we're editing data of our basket
which carries all the products that we
selected and what are we doing with the
local storage set item using this line
what we're doing is we're saving those
data of the basket inside the local
storage so the main reason for putting
these things at the top and this one at
the bottom is that we want javascript to
run these lines of code first of all so
that we can have the necessary edits and
changes on the data of our basket so
once that's done what we want javascript
to do next is that we want it to save
all the data i mean save all the edited
updated data back to the local storage
like this not
will just save available thing first of
all and then it's gonna do all the edits
which means that guys you cannot see the
updates on the local storage that's why
guys you have put the local search at
the bottom like this okay so guys i
really hope that you understood why i
wrote this at the bottom in the same way
you're going to open the increment
function here and then use this local
storage here you just cut the thing from
here like this and then put it at the
bottom like this okay save the thing
there we go done now guys let's inspect
our code okay let's just fold it first
of all now guys save the thing inspect
the code okay so now we have a zero here
right let's refresh the thing let's see
whether it works or not so first of all
let's delete the data okay refresh the
thing again let us select something here
like this
okay
uh select something here there we go
then select on this one you can see the
data here all right guys now let's test
the result this is four here it's
actually here okay every time you click
on the plus it works okay if you click
on the minus minus also works so let's
go and make it zero like this okay three
two one it should be zero right it
doesn't work but instead it's giving us
error why does it actually happen
that's because of the serial look at
this guys do you see this one here
that's because of the serial so we want
the update to run first and then we want
this line to run
okay so since it is in the opposite
direction that's why we can't see the
changes so in order to fix that guys
just cut the thing from here ctrl x put
it here like this okay
there we go now guys save the thing and
then let's look at the result okay now
let's come here and then refresh the
thing now how many things can you see
here just one piece okay click on here
done now it's zero at the same time it
remove the object from our basket
brilliant let's test it here it's three
two
one
zero gone can you see that let's test
this one as well four three two
one zero there we go guys we're
successful up to this point
all right guys so far so good now we're
gonna make the card page okay so let's
look at the finalized project the card
page should look something like this can
you see this so let me give you a small
demo this will be the total bill okay
then we're gonna have two options either
the checkout option or the clear card so
what this will do is it's gonna delete
everything from here next up do you see
this little cards here this represents
all the items that we selected from the
shop page all right and now look at this
one this is the unit price okay the
price of one single piece this is the
quantity and this is the total price and
this total price is actually calculated
by multiplying this 45 by two so if you
click on the plus you can see that the
price increased here at the same time
the total bill increases here like this
let's test again like this look at that
okay you can also decrement the thing
like this there we go let's say that you
don't want the thing so you can just
click on the cross here like this and
it's gonna entirely remove the thing
like this there we go okay something
like this look at that now let's say
that you don't want anything you don't
want to buy anything you just click on
the clear card it's going to remove
everything and then it's going to show
you an option called cart is empty cart
is empty you can go back to the home
something like this there we go you see
now let's start building the cart page
all right guys in order to make the cart
page let's go back to our vs code okay
and on the folder structure let me zoom
in a little bit so that you can see it
better here we're gonna create a new
file we're gonna name it car.html okay
card.html something like this okay now
guys follow along with me we're gonna
create a folder we're gonna name it
source so the main objective of creating
this folder is that we're gonna store
all of our style sheet and javascript
file inside here okay so that we can
manage our folder structure in a neat
and clean way okay so guys follow along
with me okay just drag the main js here
and the style css here like this okay so
since guys we changed the folder
structure here we have to go back to the
index.html okay and do you see this
links here this one and this one here we
have to we have to update this otherwise
we can see something like this can you
see this one here
so in our project no javascript and no
style sheet got applied because we
updated the folder structure here so we
have to make those updates here as well
so come here and then write source slash
save the thing scroll down to your
script here
you can write here source
slash main.js save the thing now let's
look at the result if everything goes
well you should see something like this
you see all right guys perfect let's go
back to our folder structure here this
is index.html for this page we have this
main.js file and for the card.html we're
gonna have another file we're gonna name
it card dot js something like this okay
now guys let's go back to our card html
here we're gonna write some boilerplate
code okay something like this
exclamatory sign tab done now guys we
don't have to write anything from
scratch we just copy paste lines from
the index.html okay so come back to our
index.html scroll up do you see these
three lines here this is the bootstrap
icons this is this is the link for the
style css and this is the title tag okay
just copy the three lines something like
this okay
copy the thing let's go back to our
card.html and then replace the thing
with this okay there we go done now guys
here we're gonna write the script source
control space you're gonna go to your
source and then you're gonna select the
card yes okay save the thing guys
okay guys this is the finished project
can you see this navbar here this is the
cart page if you go back to the home
page you can see the same nav bar here
which means that we don't have to build
anything from scratch we can just copy
paste the thing inside our cart page but
guys look at this can you see this one
here if i click on here it goes to the
cart page if i click on here it goes
back to the home page this is the
navigation and in order to build that
we're going to use the anchor text so
let's implement those things in our
project so guys you're going to go to
your index html first okay now in order
to do the navigation part you're going
to hit here a tab okay control space it
should lead us back to the home page
okay cut this h2 tag from here and then
we're gonna paste it here like this all
right now let's make another anchor tag
which will lead us to the cart page okay
something like this there we go now
inside here what you're going to do is
do this div here
just copy the entire thing i mean cut
the entire thing then paste it here okay
save the thing guys now do this you just
close the nav bar here like this copy
the entire thing go back to the cart
html now inside the body tag paste the
entire paste the entire thing okay then
you can also fold it like this save the
thing okay now guys let's look at the
result okay if everything goes well it
should look something like this can you
see this one here it looks odd it was
previously white in color but why is
that that's because the anchor tag
actually have some default styles which
we nee which we need to remove so come
back to our style css at the very top
here okay below the i tag we're gonna
write here a curly bracket okay td tab
text decoration none and then we're
gonna set the color to white okay
something like this
there we go guys now let's look at the
result
so it should look something like this
okay now guys look at this we can
navigate between the cart page like this
we can also go back to the home page
there you go guys so far so good but
guys there's a little bit of problem can
you see this number here it's 15 1 5 but
if you go to the card page like this
it's zero why is this actually happening
let me tell you the main reason is that
this is card.js page is totally blank it
doesn't have any data that's why we are
seeing a zero here so guys in order to
fix that thing what we're gonna do is
we're gonna look at this guys do you
remember our local storage here let me
show you
we have all the data saved here what
we're going to do is we're going to pull
this data inside our card.js okay so
guys we don't have to write anything
from scratch let's just go back to the
main.js okay now do you see this line
here let basket equal to this one so it
is already doing a job of pulling data
from the local storage so what is this
this is trying to pull data from the
local stretch if we don't have anything
only then it's gonna return us an empty
array okay
so guys let's just copy the thing and
now let's go back to the cart page page
the thing done now in order to be sure
whether i think the way that the thing
actually works or not just console.log
the thing okay console.log okay we're
gonna write here basket something like
this save the thing guys now let's look
at the result okay
so if you go to the console here you
should see data coming back from the
local stress something like this but
guys the 15 the number 15 is not here if
we go back to the home page the 15 is
here but actually not here so in order
to solve that issue guys do you remember
that we created a function inside
main.js its name was calculation do you
remember this so what's the job of this
calculation tell me guys the main job of
the calculation function is that let's
go back to our this is the cart page
okay so now let's open up this data the
main job of the calculation function is
that this is items here it got some
number okay so what the calculation
function will do is that it's gonna add
all the numbers okay and then it's gonna
show it here so guys in order to solve
this issue let's go back to our main.js
okay here let's copy the entire
calculation function along with this
statement okay just copy the thing let's
go back to our card.js and then paste
the thing here now guys we don't need
this one anymore let's remove the thing
save the thing guys now guys let's look
at the result if everything goes well
then you can see 15 here if you go back
you have the 15 here okay let's select
something else let's say that we're
gonna select these things up to let's
say 15 okay now you can see that
previously it was 15 now it's 30 it's 30
right now if you click on here then you
can see that the thing also got updated
along with the home page next up guys go
back to your vs code on the main.js and
then you're going to scroll to the very
top do you see this variable here this
variable name is shop items data what is
this actually this is an array which
carries all the data of the products
that are listed on the shop page we can
also create a separate file for this
gigantic data
in order to do that what you're gonna do
is you're gonna first of all fold the
thing okay then cut the thing from here
okay now on the folder structure look at
this inside the source click here then
you're gonna create a new file you're
gonna name it data dot js something like
this then you're gonna hit enter the
variable that you have cut you're gonna
paste it here like this okay let me zoom
out a little bit i'm gonna scroll up do
you see this one here it got here save
the thing guys now if you look at the
result screen you can see that the
entire thing broke down something like
this you see shop items data is not
defined so in order to include this
data.js back into the main.js do you
know what you're going to do you're
going to go to your index.html and use
this line here before this one you're
going to include it like this look
script source okay one second script
source control space you're gonna go to
your source then you're gonna select
data gs okay save the thing now let's
look at the result guys now guys look at
that we have no errors so guys i really
hope that you understood how i broke
down a big file into two different
smaller files okay in the same way what
you're gonna do is you're gonna go to
your cart html okay and before this line
you're gonna include the same
script something like this look script
source control space go to your source
then you're gonna select data js save
the thing okay all right guys now we're
gonna start writing the html markup
inside our body tag okay so below this
nav bar we're gonna create a div with
the id label something like this look
hashtag label okay at the same time it's
gonna have a class name of text center
dot text minus center tap there we go
our main objective is to target this
inside javascript and to target this one
inside style css okay
below this line we're going to create
another day with a class name shopping
cart look at this dot shopping
minus cart okay at the same time we're
going to give it a id of the identical
name something like this look hashtag
shopping
okay
minus cart
tap there we go we can target this in
javascript this will be targeted inside
style css now guys you might ask me a
question like what's the main reason for
creating this one and the main reason
for creating this one let me show you
guys if we go back to the finalists
project here okay let's go to the cart
page now do you see this component here
the total bill and the checkout clear
card this component will be actually
built inside here
and do you see this one here inside here
what we're gonna do is we're gonna build
this cards here so guys i really hope
that you understood why i created these
two tips okay
we're not gonna write anything inside
these two divs we're gonna create these
two components using javascript so first
of all do this guys first of all this is
id here we're gonna select both of them
inside the javascript okay first of all
target the label okay let's go back to
our card.js and at the top what you're
gonna do is you're gonna write a let
label okay since this is this is an id
you're gonna write here document okay
document
dot get element by id you're gonna write
bracket single quota double quote paste
the thing okay done next up you're gonna
tell let
shopping card okay shopping
cart
equal to document dot get element by id
okay bracket single quote or double
quote like this let's go back to our
card.html then you're gonna copy this
one this is id here yeah copy the thing
let's go back here and paste the thing
like this there we go done
okay guys so far so good now guys do you
see this one here on the finalized
project we have all the cards here okay
we're gonna target we're gonna build
this one first of all and then we're
gonna build this one later on okay so in
order to build all of these cars we're
gonna create a function the functional
name will be generate card items follow
along with me guys below the calculation
we're gonna write here let generate
generate
card items okay this is gonna be an es6
error function something like this okay
then we're gonna write curly bracket
okay guys listen to me carefully inside
this function we're gonna have two cases
the first case is when we will have data
on the basket and the second case is
when we will have no data on the basket
let me show you what do i mean by that
first of all save the thing okay let's
go back to the finalized project okay so
look at this guys this is the first case
when we have some data on the local
stretch let's say that we don't have any
data so if we have data on the local
storage then the thing will look
something like this but if we don't have
any data on the local storage then what
will it
then what will it look like it will look
something like this look if i clear the
card then it's gonna look like this okay
cart is empty back to home so in order
to generate both of these two components
together we're gonna use the if else
statement okay in order to do that let's
come back to the card.js and inside here
we're gonna write an if-else statement
look at this guys follow along with me
so guys we're gonna write the if-else
statement here okay if bracket curly
bracket okay on the next line we're
gonna write else curly bracket okay so
inside this bracket you're gonna write
basket dot length okay
is not equal to zero okay so what do i
mean by this if else statement by this i
mean that when the basket length is not
equal to zero you're gonna write
you're gonna run this code else you're
gonna run this code okay so let's test
the result okay so we're gonna right
here console.okay console.log
okay we're gonna write here basket
is not empty
okay and now inside this else statement
we're gonna write console.log okay
console.log we're gonna write here
basket is
totally
empty okay now after saving the result
just copy this thing and then we're
gonna invoke the function here okay now
bracket save the thing let's look at the
result okay so this is a result screen
here you're gonna go to the cart html
page okay like this can you see this one
here it is written basket is not empty
but guys let's go to the application
local story okay let's clear the entire
thing now let's refresh the thing go
back to the console okay you can see
that basket is totally empty so guys i
really hope that you understood how this
if else statement is working okay
so guys let's remove the console from
here like this okay and before writing
the if statement let's finish the else
statement first of all okay so what
you're gonna do is you're gonna scroll
up this is the shopping cart here yeah
what is it doing it is targeting the id
from the html element okay so copy the
thing and then scroll down
paste the thing here and then you can
write here dot inner html equal to
backticks okay we're gonna make it just
blank like this and on the next line
what you're gonna do is do remember this
label here which is also coming from the
html element okay just copy the thing
scroll down here okay paste the thing
like this then you can write hit dot
inner html equal to what we're gonna
write here is look at this first of all
you're gonna backtick okay then you're
gonna right here h2 tab and guys here
you're gonna write card is empty okay
something like this
empty and on the next one you're gonna
write here a tab okay so what this will
lead us to this anchor tag will lead us
to the index.html which is the home page
okay index
dot html okay so inside here what we're
gonna write is we're gonna create a
button look at this b o t t o n
dot we're gonna attach a home button
class name okay something like this then
you're gonna hit tab there we go now can
you see this one here it's written class
name don't do it guys otherwise it's not
going to work so it should only be a
class not class name now inside here we
can write back to home something like
this so back to
home done save the thing now let's look
at the result guys now guys if we look
at the result screen it looks something
like this the cart is empty and back to
home page we're seeing this component
here now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna put it on the exact center in
order to do that come back to your style
css here okay and at the very bottom
come to at the very bottom here like
this and we're gonna write first of all
a comment okay so we're gonna write a
comment like this
okay star exclamatory sign here we're
gonna write style rules for style
rules for
label and
and some buttons okay something like
this save the thing now below this one
we're gonna write text center do you
remember this guys one second uh on the
card.html do you see that we have a
class of text center just copy this from
here okay come back here and paste it
like this okay dot paste curly bracket
inside here you can write ta tab then
center
okay then you can write margin bottom 20
pixels okay mb tab 20 pixel save the
thing now let's throw the result guys
the result look should look something
like this
and guys the main reason for putting the
margin bottom 20 pixel is that if you
look at the finalized project here then
you can see this gap here this gap is
actually margin bottom of 20 pixel you
can't see it here that's because we
don't have those cards getting generated
here okay this is back to home button
we're gonna style it right now so let's
go back to our style css here we're
gonna write home button one second guys
let's first of all come back to the cart
html okay
not here sorry guys card js
and this is class name here home button
copy the thing come back to your style
css and then you're gonna hear dot paste
okay then right here curly bracket so
you're gonna set the background color
bgc tab remove this thing and then
you're gonna hit ctrl space do you see
this color here two one two five two
nine get this one okay next up you're
gonna write the color to be white okay
next up we're gonna remove the border
okay border none okay then we're gonna
apply some padding of six pixel to all
sides okay next up we're gonna add the
border radius to three pixel okay border
radius three pixel okay guys next up we
also need a little bit of cursor pointer
okay curve boy tap save the thing let's
look at the result okay it looks
something like this but guys can see
this card is empty on the back to home
button there is no gap in between let's
apply some gap in order to apply this
gap just come here and then right empty
uh 10 pixel tab there we go margin top
10 pixels save the thing let's look at
the result can you see this one here we
have a little we have a little bit of
gap here so far so good guys now let's
test the thing if you click on back to
home it should lead you back to the home
page can you see that guys perfect let's
go back here like this there we go
so guys it's working perfectly fine but
here's the question actually why are we
seeing this component the main reason
for seeing this component is let me show
you guys so do you remember this
function here on the card.js we have it
okay generate card items we have if else
statement here so the if statement will
run only when the local stress is not
empty and the else will run when the
local storage is empty look at this guys
we don't have anything on the basket
it's totally zero right let's go back to
the home page here let's select
something okay i have selected this
thing here so now the local stress is
not empty our basket is not empty if you
go to the cart page now look at this
this component is not rendering again
why is that guys that's because now the
else is not running the if statement is
actually running but it is not defined
it's totally blank that's why we can't
see anything here let's go back to the
home page here look at this now let's
remove the thing like this okay let's
make it zero let's come back here look
at this we can again see the component
that's because this time the else is
running
so now guys let's actually define the if
statement here okay
so guys follow along with me so on the
if statement we're gonna write a return
here so what is it gonna return look at
this we're gonna scroll to the very top
this is shopping cart here yeah copy the
thing scroll down here and then we're
gonna paste the thing like this okay now
we're gonna write here dot inner html
equal to we're gonna target the basket
do you remember the basket where is the
basket the basket is actually here and
what is this this is a array which
carries all of our selected products
okay inside the basket we're gonna make
a map like this okay then bracket we're
going to write a es6 error function like
this next up we're going to write x here
the main reason for writing the x is
that let me show you one second guys uh
let's go back to the home page here
let's select something okay
let's select something like this let's
go to our uh
local storage here like this
where is it uh let's come here here
application local storage okay guys this
is the local storage data the main
reason for writing this x is that is
gonna target all of these objects one by
one one by one
okay guys that's why i wrote this x here
okay you can write anything you wish no
problem okay i'm just gonna keep here x
now next up here i'm gonna write a curly
bracket okay enter next up guys let's
return something again okay we're gonna
return here a template literal so we're
gonna write here back t okay now inside
here we're gonna create a day with the
class name cart item look at this dot
card minus item okay tab and this is
class name here which should be only
class otherwise it's not gonna work okay
save the thing let's write something
here okay hello like this save the thing
let's look at the result there we go if
we go back to the cart page you can see
some hello here one second guys ken says
hello hello hello why is it repeating
four times okay you might have a
question like why is it repeating if you
recall what did i tell you the x where's
the x guys this x will target all the
data from the local storage one by one
one by one and then it's gonna run this
function here can you see this one here
it's gonna target all of them one by one
and then it's gonna tag and then it's
gonna run this function that's why we
got the hello four times but let's say
that uh one second guys how many data do
we have here four one two three four
let's say that i'm gonna make something
zero okay i don't want anything here if
you go to the cart page right now you
can see three hello why is that that's
because we only have three items
selected inside our basket now there's
something strange here this is little
like one second let's let me zoom in do
you see this uncommon uh comma here we
don't need the comma in order to remove
that comma just come back here and do
use this here
just come you just come here and then
you can write dot join okay bracket
single quote or double quote like this
save the thing now guys let's look at
the result okay you can see that the
strange comma is gone brilliant let me
just scroll out from here like this and
this is the thing that we don't want
guys we want it to look something like
this okay so in order to make the thing
we have to
write nice code here okay so let's get
started let's remove the hello from here
and then we're gonna hit enter okay
inside here we're gonna first of all
include the image do you remember the
image guys so i'm gonna write here img
tab okay the source will be
the source of the image will actually
come from the data js can you see this
one here data.js yeah we have all the
data here okay so look at this guys did
we include this on the card html or not
yes or no let's just check the thing
okay let's go to our card.html and look
at this okay so before the card.js we
have the data.js which means that we can
freely use this one this variable inside
our card js let me show you copy the
thing come back to the card yes first of
all save the entire thing okay now if
you write here console look like this
look at this i'm gonna write here a
small console.log okay console.log
bracket page the thing okay shop items
data we're just coming from where data
gs okay now look at this i'm gonna save
the entire thing let's go and look at
the result okay we're gonna hit f12 go
to the console you can see the data
array four and it carries all the data
of the products that are selected i mean
that are listed on the shop page look at
that it got the description it got the
id image name price etc so far so good
guys now guys let's go back to our vs
code on the main.js okay so not major
sorry card chess let's remove the thing
from here and now what we're going to do
is we're going to come to our if
statement here okay
now guys look at this x can you see this
x here so what does it carry what is
this x this x is actually a object look
at this let me show you so we're gonna
hear console okay.log we're gonna say x
save the thing so what will happen is
this x will run four times why is that
that's because guys not four times sorry
it's gonna run three times that's
because guys look at the application
local storage how many things do we have
on the basket three things okay
that's why the x will run three times
now look at the console can you see this
one here we got the id and the item now
guys can you see this id here i o y
something i o y look at the first three
letters i o y according to the id okay
according to this id let's search inside
our data yes look at this let's come
back here on the data.js and where is
the o y here is it okay can i see this
one here this is our i o y
id now look at this guys what does this
object carry this object carries our
image it carries the price and it also
carries the name so do you know what i'm
gonna do guys using this id i'm using
this x id i'm gonna grab the data from
the data.js and then i'm gonna target
this image do you see this image here
i'm gonna target this image and then i'm
gonna get it inside the source let me
show you how i do the thing so what i'm
gonna do is first of all i'm gonna
destructure the x okay why do i
destructure the x that's because look at
this do you see this one here we have
both the id and the item we don't need
the item right now we only need the item
okay so in order to just target id we
just destructure the thing like this
look at this let curly bracket okay id
comma then we're gonna write here which
one item okay
equal to x done now we can freely use
the id
which is coming from this x okay next up
guys we're going to make a search
function look at this let search
uh search equal to so what are we
searching from we are actually searching
from this variable can you see this
variable here yeah just copy the
variable which is from the data.js okay
come back here and then we're going to
put it here like this okay so search
equals shop items data then we're going
to write here a find okay dot find
bracket okay now inside here we're gonna
make a es6 error function something like
this okay now you can write anything you
wish no problem but let's make it simple
guys let's write
a y here okay you can write anything no
problem guys let's just write y okay now
what are we searching against what are
we searching against let's see so look
at this id here guys where is this
coming from this is actually coming from
the basket okay and where is this y
coming from this is coming from the data
js okay so what do i want i want to
match this id with this id which means
that whatever id we have on the basket
we want to match that
with the id
from our database something like this
let me show you okay so we're going to
come here and then we're going to write
here y dot id
is triple equal to id
this id is coming from here which is
from the basket and this is coming from
the database which is from the data js
okay and then what we're gonna write is
you're gonna write all statement here or
you're gonna make it blank like this so
what do i mean by this i mean by this is
that if you find something then return
it but if you can't find anything then
just return it empty array here like
this okay so far so good guys save the
thing now guys we can freely use the
image from the database okay how do i do
it look at this come back to the card.js
and use this one here we're gonna come
here and then we're gonna remove the
thing we're gonna hit dollar sign curly
bracket search dot img save the thing
let's look at the result okay the image
is huge can you see that but we got all
the images in order to make it smaller
let's uh come back here and then we're
gonna select a width here okay width
like this equal to then we're gonna
write here
double quote 100 like this okay save the
thing let's look at the result okay
there we go our images got smaller can
you see this one here okay why do we
have only three images here the main
reason for having three images is that
look at that look at your application
local stretch how many things did you
select from the basket how many things
do you have on the basket these are the
products that you selected from the shop
page you have only three that's why you
have the three which one is missing the
casual shirt is missing okay let's go
back to the home page here's the casual
shirt okay so if you select something
from here let's look at the result you
got now four images okay if you go back
here let's say that you don't want
t-shirts remove the t-shirt from here
let's go back here there we go we don't
have any casual shirts here okay so far
so good guys now we also need to apply
some styles and get the data here so
that it looks nice just like this one
okay so in order to do those things go
back to your vs code and below the image
we're going to create another div with
the class name details look at this dot
details okay tab and this is class name
here i'm really sorry guys you have to
remove this one from here it should be
only class equal to details okay now
guys inside these details we're gonna
have two div and one h3 tag let me show
you what i mean by that okay so you're
gonna write here dot
title minus price minus x something like
this look title
okay minus price minus x tab also give
an indent here like this okay now let's
go to the next line and we're going to
create another div which will be named
card buttons like this look dot cart
minus b o t t o and s tab on the next
line you're gonna write a h3 tag okay
something like this now guys what is the
main reason for creating these three
html elements let me show you guys do
you see this is title price and the x
okay so if i compare that with the
finalized project look at this do you
see this one here we have a something
called casual shared we have the price
and we have the cross sign okay so using
this div this is div here yeah using
this div we're gonna create this three
things together okay next up we have
something called um card buttons can you
see this one here so using this one
we're gonna create this this is this
button here along with the plus minus
and the quantity here yeah so guys using
this one we're gonna build up this
component here okay and this is price
here we're gonna display that price
inside the h3 tag okay so i really hope
guys that you understood why i wrote the
thing
okay guys now let's put some gap in
between them so that it looks nice and
understandable now inside the first one
inside the first div what we're gonna
write here is look at this follow along
with me guys let's give some indentation
here like this we're gonna have two
things first one is the h4 tag okay tab
next up we're gonna have an icon which
should be the cross sign so in order to
get the icon just come over to your
icons
icons.getbootstrap.com
and here you just write here just a x
now scroll to the very bottom the x is
actually here where is it um here is it
okay x minus lg click on this one then
copy the link okay let's go back to our
um card js okay now paste the thing like
this okay save the thing now inside this
h4
we're gonna write a p tag okay uh first
of all let's give it some indentation
like this p tab now inside here you're
gonna write dollar sign curly bracket
search dot nick so where is this name
coming from this name is actually coming
from the data.js this is name here
casual shared then we have office shirt
etc okay i really hope that you
understood how i'm doing this thing okay
save the thing now let's look at the
result okay if you look at the result it
will look something like this can you
see this one here we have the office
shirt and then we also have an x here
but don't worry guys even though it
looks bad we're gonna use styles to make
the thing look nice okay just follow
along with me what i'm doing let's go
back by the way guys can i see this x
here we're gonna make it in red color so
let's do that right now so do you see
this um where is it this is b minus x
minus lg copy the thing now let's go
back to your main uh where is it style
css so guys you're gonna come back to
your style css at the very bottom okay
here you're gonna write here dot paste
okay then curly bracket bgc not bgc
sorry it's gonna be color we're gonna
set it to red color okay and then we can
also optionally give some font to it
okay font weight we can set it to bold
okay dol they say the thing now guys
let's look at the result okay
now you can see that you can notice that
the x is actually red in color brilliant
guys now let's go back to our vs code
after zooming out uh where is it here
on the card.js okay below this p tag
you're gonna create another p tag which
will display the price okay of the
single quantity unit okay so just right
here dollar sign space dollar sign curly
bracket again this dollar sign will be
the currency and this one will be the
variable okay so here you can write
search
dot price okay this price is also coming
from where it is coming from the data js
which is here can i see this one here
yeah let's go back here and now let's
look at the result okay it should look
something like this cancel this one here
we have the office shared here where the
price here and then we have the
delete button here as well so far so
good guys now we're gonna style it in a
way that it looks nice okay in order to
make it nice first of all let's go back
to our uh style css not style scissors
sorry card html and guys do you remember
this one here shopping cart copy this
thing okay like this now let's go back
to our style css and at the bottom here
let's create a comment first of all okay
comment like this
we're gonna write here exclamatory sign
and then
we're gonna write here style okay rules
for shopping cart page the thing okay
done now here you go right here dot
paste curly bracket so guys how did i
actually do the finalized project okay
how did i do this i actually use
something called display grid okay this
is a single column okay so that it it is
also responsive look at that if i hit
f12 look at this if i go to the mobile
screen it is irresponsive like that okay
so how did i do the thing i actually use
a single column and each of this card is
320 pixels
in width so guys let's do the same thing
with our project okay so you're going to
come back to your style css here you're
going to write display great dg tab on
the next line you got a gtc tab okay on
the repeating i write one comma why one
okay the main reason for putting one is
that we want only one column okay that's
why i have put here one then you can
write here 320 pixel okay by 320 pixel i
mean that the width should be at the
width of the column should be 320 pixel
same thing guys now let's look at the
result okay we can't actually see any
changes unless we set some border around
all these cards okay in order to set the
border around these cards so that we can
see it better do follow along with me
guys just copy the comment from here and
put it here okay so is it is gonna be
style rules for cart item where am i
getting the cart item from i'm actually
getting the cart item from here you see
this one here so just copy the thing
from here let's go back to our card html
no sorry not here style css okay come
here and then you're gonna hit dot paste
okay curly bracket here right here
border okay where's the border
border 2px solid red not red sorry black
or you can also use that hashtag you can
also use this color here okay say the
thing now guys let's look at the result
okay it will look something like this
next up guys we're going to put this
entire thing on the exact center we're
gonna have some gap in between them and
there's this pointed
corner here we're gonna make it rounded
okay in order to make those changes just
come back to your shopping cart first of
all and then we're gonna write here uh
one second guys we're gonna write here
jc c tab okay justify content center
okay if you look at the result it has
come if it has moved to the exact center
okay next up guys we're gonna give some
gap in between these cars can i see this
one here we have no gaps okay so we're
gonna write here um gap of 15 pixel okay
15 pixels say the thing let's look at
the result okay there we go we have some
gap let's make this rounded
let's make this pointed corners rounded
okay in order to make that thing just
come back to your uh cart item here okay
then you're gonna write here border
radius of five pixel okay five px save
the thing let's look at the result
there we go it looks something like this
all right guys now look at our image
here and the content here how does it
look like it looks like a column but we
don't want that we want it to behave
like a row like this okay in order to
solve the issue do you know what we're
gonna do you're gonna target which one
let's come back here or we're gonna
target the card html and then we're
gonna write a display flex look at this
df tab save the thing guys now look at
the result it looks like our
finalized project here you see brilliant
guys but look at this guys this is
office shirt hundred dollar and the x it
is now behaving like a column can you
see that but we want to but we want it
to behave like a row something like this
okay in order to do that thing what
we're going to do is we're going to
first of all go back to our main.js
sorry so not mean just card chess okay i
just make some mistakes here so guys
come back to your card yes and use this
one here this is the class name by the
way guys can i see this one here i made
a small error my apologies guys i it is
not class name it should be only class
now let's fix this one as well and every
time you see something class name remove
the name it should only be class
otherwise it's not gonna work okay
let's copy this thing guys it's title
minus price minus x okay after copying
the thing come back to your style css by
the way guys can you see this one here i
mistakenly wrote two comments of the
same name so this is shopping cart here
yeah it should match this one and use
this card item here it should match here
so let's actually remove this one and
write style rules for cart minus item
done guys now let's scroll to the very
bottom here we're gonna write dot paste
okay then we're gonna have curly racket
okay inside here we're gonna write uh
display flex tab save the thing now guys
let's look at the result
it should look something like this but
guys can you see this one here this x
and these things are not aligned on the
exact center okay
so in order to solve this issue look at
this i'm just going to come back to all
my vs code let me just keep it here like
this okay you keep your eyes here okay
and then i'm gonna write the code here
look at this i'm gonna use aic tab the
moment i hit the save look at this they
are now aligned on the exact center
right
and next up guys this is x here i'm
gonna put it at the corner here
in order to do that we're gonna write jc
sv okay justify content space between
say the thing now let's look at the
result can you see that it didn't work
why didn't it work guys let me show you
a trick so if in order to understand
something like why a certain element is
not working always add this okay border
okay 2px solid red then you can see the
entire element here can you see this one
here this is the entire element the main
reason for the x not put coming at the
end here is that there's this content
here it is fixed it is locked okay it
cannot expand itself so in order to make
it expand
what we're gonna do is we're gonna give
here a weight look at this we're gonna
set it a weight of 195 pixels like this
okay save the thing let's look at the
result there we go kennedy's x now
expanding here
brilliant guys so far so good now we
don't actually need the border anymore
you can keep it or you can just make a
comment like this okay save the thing
there we go it looks nice but guys look
at this one this is 300 then we have the
100 dollar here we don't want it here we
want it to be here just like this one
can you see this one here yeah
so let's make those necessary changes
okay so that it looks like this so let's
go back to your
card.js first of all let's expand the
thing okay
do you see this h4 tag yeah we're gonna
put here another class here okay class
one second
class
name equal to is gonna be double quote
we're gonna write here title
minus price so why did i put both the
title minus price that's because this
tag actually carries both the name i
mean the title and the price that's why
i name it i named it like this
so guys i'm just gonna copy the thing
let's go back to our style css and at
the bottom i'm gonna write dot paste
curly bracket so here i'm gonna write
display flex okay aic tab for the align
item center okay and now let's save the
thing let's look at the result it should
look something like this but guys we
don't have any gap in between them can
you see that so in order to put some gap
let's put gap of 10 pixel inside the
title minus price here is it okay so
we're gonna actually gap of how much 10
pixel okay now look at this guys we have
a gap of 10 pixel here okay this is
price here we want to style it in a way
that it looks nice just like this one
okay so follow along with me guys so
where is this actually located let's
first of all locate that you're gonna go
to your um card.js okay now where is it
it's actually here you can see this one
here search dot price on the p tag yeah
so we're gonna attach a class here okay
look at this we're gonna write here
class okay equal to double quote it's
gonna be card item price okay cart minus
item minus price okay now copy this
thing from here let's go back to your
stuff first of all save the thing okay
copy after copying the thing go back to
your style css okay and at the bottom
you can write dot paste okay curly
bracket inside here you're gonna write
first of all bgc look at this bgc tab
okay you're gonna select select a color
which we specified two one two uh
control space okay if you forgot the
thing like this okay two one two five to
nine then we're gonna set the color to
uh white something like this okay
um there we go now if you look at the
result after saving it should look
something like this right we're gonna
apply some padding and some border area
so that it looks nice okay so in order
to do those things just come here and
then you're gonna write border radius of
four pixels something like this okay
then we're gonna apply some padding of
three pixel on the top and bottom and
six pixel on the left and right
something like this let's look at the
result guys after saving now look at
that it looks nice okay let's zoom out
okay
next step guys to use buttons here yeah
do you think that this looks very
familiar yes it looks familiar if you go
to the home page
we actually imported this component
inside our
cart page okay that's why it looks
similar that's why it looks identical so
we're not gonna write it we're just
gonna copy paste some lines from our
main.js okay so what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go to your main.js where is
it
main.js okay then you're gonna open the
generate shop function okay now where is
the div with the class name buttons here
is it can i see this one here so just
click on here and then there's this
thread here yeah so following this
thread you just copy the entire thing
from here okay
after copying the entire thing just come
back to your card.js okay
next up do you see this one here you can
just easily remove the thing because we
copied the same thing right then you're
gonna paste it like this okay save the
thing and give some indentation here
like this okay so in order to give some
indentation do this okay so you select
everything inside the div then you're
gonna hit tab like this okay
come here and you're gonna see like a
tab like this it should look something
like this okay
or you can also give another indent here
like this there we go save the thing now
let's look at the result okay
uh where is it here is it okay there we
go can you see this one here we have the
plus and the minus icons
along with the number indicator here as
well if you click on the plus or if you
click on the minus it's not gonna work
why is that that's because uh look at
this card js okay if i close up this one
uh we don't have the increment and the
decrement function that's why it's not
gonna work but if you open up this one
if we scroll down can you see this one
here the i this is the minus button
right it got the decrement here and this
i here where is it this is the plus it
got the increment here even though they
got it here it's still not gonna work
that's because guys we didn't define
these functions at the bottom
we're gonna do that right now but before
that um do you see this one here yeah we
don't need this one okay so what you're
gonna do is you're gonna remove the
thing from here okay
and one second guys let me make it a
better like this
give me a second there we go okay it
should look something like this now once
again guys if you scroll up do you
remember this item here yeah you can
just copy the item which is actually
coming from where this x where is this x
coming from this x is coming from the
basket okay just copy the item from here
scroll down to your um here quantity
okay just right here dollar sign curly
bracket
pays the thing done save it now let's
look at the result now you can see the
number getting shown here live
so guys this number here represents the
quantity of the item that you selected
okay but still if you click on the plus
on the minus it's not gonna work okay in
order to make the thing work look at
this guys i'm literally i'm literally
gonna go to the main.js okay one second
let me just close this thing zoom out a
little bit do you see this increment
decrement i'm gonna copy the thing from
here okay after copying the thing go
back to your card.js at the bottom okay
paste the entire thing like this save it
first of all do this you just close it
like this okay scroll up and then you
close it like this okay
also along with these guys we also need
to get the update otherwise we can't see
the changes on the html i mean on the
result screen just copy the update
function and come back here and then
paste the thing like this okay save the
thing you can also fold it like this and
there we go let's look at the result
okay after saving everything on the
card.js okay
so if everything goes well if you click
on the plus it's gonna work perfectly
fine not only that guys you can see this
one can you see this one here it is also
working perfectly fine look at that
right click let's click on the plus it's
working let's click on the minus there
we go it's working perfectly fine okay
all right guys there's an issue with our
code this is buttons here yeah the plus
sign works totally fine no problem but
the problem is with the minus every time
i go and hit a zero the thing this card
doesn't remove itself automatically but
we want the thing to remove itself
automatically something like this look
uh let's say that we have a four here
okay or let's say i want to remove this
thing look at this three two one zero
you see it removed itself automatically
in order to implement the same system
into our project the solution guys it's
very very very simple follow along with
me guys do you see this decrement
function here yeah first of all you're
gonna open the thing okay and this is
generate cart items here yeah just copy
the thing and now this is comment here
i'm gonna remove the comment and then
i'm gonna paste the thing like this okay
now look at this i'm gonna save the
thing let's look at the result okay this
is the this is our project result so
let's go to zero okay three two one zero
there we go it went away automatically
how is this actually happening guys let
me explain okay so guys do you remember
this line here yeah what is it actually
doing its main job is to filter out all
the objects which has the item of zero
so once it's done filtering out those
data
is gonna re-render our
cards using this function here you see
this one here it is actually used to
re-render our cards so if i scroll up
where is this actually coming from where
is this trigger leading us to this is
gonna lead us to the function of
generate cart items which actually helps
us to generate these cards here can i
see this one here yeah so that's how the
mechanics actually work okay first of
all it's gonna remove those
unnecessary data the data which has an
item of zero and then it's gonna run the
function which helps us to re-render all
the cards let me show you a live demo
okay
so how much is this five let's try to go
to zero okay four three two one the next
time i hit a minus here is gonna become
zero once it turns zero do you know
which line it will run the moment it
runs zero this line will run and then
it's gonna re-render the cards using
this one okay that's how the mechanic
actually works look at this if you click
on this one there we go the data is gone
at the same time the card is gone as
well so guys i really really really hope
that you understood how the mechanics
actually work okay let's go back to the
home page and let's select some products
okay so i'm gonna select this products
here like this uh there we go okay let's
go back to the cart page and now guys
let's compare this with our finalized
project okay look at this so we have a
price can you see this price here yeah
this is the total price of the item that
you selected along with the quantity
okay so if you click on the plus like
this look at this the quantity increased
along with the price increase as well so
how do you build a component like this
very simple very easy guys follow along
with me okay so we're gonna first of all
do what we're gonna go back to our card
just here do you see this function which
is the generate card items yeah this one
okay so we're gonna scroll down slowly
okay after the buttons do you remember
this h3 tag yeah we're gonna write the
thing inside here okay
so guys follow along with me let me zoom
in a little bit okay so here i'm gonna
first of all write a dollar sign to
represent the currency okay then we're
gonna write here dollar sign curly
bracket inside here do you remember the
item guys where is the item here is the
item okay can i see that first of all
copy the thing okay then scroll down um
here okay
paste the item here so what does the
item represent let me tell you after
saving the thing let's look at the
result can you see this one here yeah 14
this number here this is the quantity
this quantity is actually getting
represented here this quantity is
getting printed here but we want what do
we want we want the quantity to get
multiplied by this number here can you
see this one here this is the price of
the unit this is the price of one unit
we want to multiply this with the item
quantity
and then we will get the final result
here so in order to do something like
this let me show you how to do the thing
scroll up do you see this one here
search dot price copy the thing scroll
down on the item okay you're gonna hit a
star then paste the thing done save the
thing now guys let's look at the result
there we go guys can you see this one
here yeah this is the init price and
this is the quantity it got multiplied
and it gave us the result here this is
the thing that we are expecting but
here's one thing that we don't expect
every time you click on the plus like
this we want the price to get updated
but it is not updating right it's not
working perfectly fine but every time
every time you hit the minus can you see
that the minus actually works but the
plus doesn't work why is that guys it
looks quite strange in order to solve
the issue first of all let's look at the
decrement function one second let's
actually close this one like this let's
look at the decrement function guys what
are we doing every time we click on the
minus the decrement function runs
eventually this generate cut item also
runs so why is this important what does
it actually do this helps us to
re-render our cards with the updated
data that's why guys that's why only the
minus works but not the plus in order to
solve the issue look at this very simple
very easy just copy the thing okay
fold your decrement open the increment
okay now scroll down guys
do you see this console here yeah i'm
gonna remove the thing paste it like
this save the thing it's gonna solve is
gonna solve our issue let's look at the
result guys every time you click on the
plus there we go
look at that it's working perfectly fine
you see now let's try to click on the
minus there we go it's working brilliant
okay
all right guys so far so good next up
this is delete button here yeah we're
going to make a function named remove
item so that every time we click on this
one it's going to remove the entire card
here okay so let's go and build that up
so in order to build it up go back to
your car gs and below the update what
we're gonna write we're gonna write a
function okay that remove item okay
remove item is gonna be es6 error
function like this okay now inside here
we're gonna pass the id so why did i
pass the id let me tell you okay so the
thing is how does does how will
javascript exactly know that which card
that you are selecting okay all of this
id i mean all of these cards has a
unique id okay
using that unique id we're gonna delete
the thing okay that's why i have
included the id in the parameter
next up guys we need to copy this and
invoke it in the place where the x icon
is actually select located okay do you
see this one here yeah title price minus
x inside here you have the icon here
okay so on the icon you can actually on
click okay on click equal to double
quote okay paste the thing invoke it
here next up guys scroll updates id here
copy the id scroll down you can write
here dollar sign curly bracket id done
now in order to test whether the thing
actually works or not you're gonna
scroll down here look at this okay then
you're gonna have let selected sorry
selected item
item equal to id
okay guys next up we're gonna write a
console.look okay console.log we're
gonna write a selected item like this
save the thing let's look at the result
okay so let's hit f12 okay and let's go
to the console every time you click on
let's say the x like this can see this
one here we got the entire html element
inside here which we don't actually want
we want only the id only the unique
number here can i see this one here yeah
so in order to target only that we're
gonna write a selected item dot id only
save the thing let's look at the result
okay there we go every time you click on
the x can see this one here we can only
get the unique id for which is actually
located for each and every one of these
cards something like this you see so far
so good guys by the way can you see this
console here i mean there's this data
here they're coming from the console
let's remove that thing okay so in order
to remove those things go back to your
uh generic card items okay here is the
console let's remove the thing from here
okay because it looks kind of odd okay
once that's done guys let's scroll down
to the very bottom here um where is it
here's the console okay let's make it a
comment here
now guys let's look at the result okay
every time
every time i click the cross do you know
what will happen every time i click on
the cross it's gonna remove that object
from the local stretch let me show you
so if i go back to the local storage
here uh where is the item 19 okay this
is the quantity of 19 here is the 19
here right every time i click on the x i
want to remove this entire object from
here okay in order to do that we're
gonna use something called a filter
function so let's do the exact same
thing okay so we're gonna write here
basket okay basket equal to
basket.filter okay
next up i'm gonna use a es6 error
function inside here like this okay now
we can you can write here anything no
problem in the arguments but let's keep
it simple let's write here x okay so
inside the x what we're gonna target is
we're targeting against the id because
that's the thing that is only unique so
we're going to target x dot id so what
i'm doing is that using this x of the
filter function i'm targeting all of
these objects one by one and since i
targeted the id here what i'm doing is
i'm targeting and matching against all
the id okay
so now let's come back here and then i'm
gonna write here not equal to selected
item dot id which is this one okay
copy this thing and put it here like
this okay so what this will do is that
whichever item you click on the cross
what is gonna do is it's gonna remove
that thing
it's gonna remove that
item from the cart and then it's gonna
update our basket okay so since the
update will come to the basket only but
we also want the update to go to our
local storage as well so in order to do
that just open up either one of them
increment or the decrement okay like
this now scroll down you have a line
called local storage dot set item copy
the thing you don't have to write okay
just copy the thing scroll down do this
remove item here on the function paste
the thing like this okay done save it
now guys let's go and look at the result
okay if you come back here let's click
on the x okay so what is the number here
8 where is it it's actually here every
time you click on the x the number and
the object actually goes away but the
object itself i mean the card itself
doesn't go away but it goes away every
time you refresh the page but we don't
want this behavior we want it to
update itself automatically so in order
to do that what we're gonna do is look
at this it's very simple guys we're
gonna re-render our components okay
we're gonna re-render all of our cards
every time we select the cross button
okay so in order to do that
copy this thing okay copy the thing
scroll down and then
paste it here like this okay save the
thing now guys let's look at the result
okay so every time let's say the casual
shirt i don't need the casual shirt so
i'm gonna hit the x like this there we
go it is removing here and reviewing
removing here at the same time let's
select this one like this there we go
it's removing everything and it's
working perfectly fine but guys look at
this can you see this one here card is
empty why is that that's because we
don't have any data here okay let's go
back and then let's select something
okay
something like this and now let's go to
the cart page like this there we go okay
let's test it again let's click on here
it's going here and it's removing itself
here as well so far so good guys
now guys let's look at our finalized
project which is here can you see this
component here yeah total bill and the
checkout clear cut we're gonna make this
button i mean we're gonna make this
component right now in order to make
something like this follow along with me
guys we're gonna create a function and
we're gonna name it
total amount so that it can calculate
all the total amount of our
bill okay so we're going to make a es6
error function let total
amount okay equal to is going to be es6
error function like this something like
this there we go okay now inside here
we're gonna have two cases
the first case is when we have data on
the local storage and the other cases
when we don't have any data on the local
storage okay just like this one let me
show you
just like the generate card items how
many cases do we have here two cases
so the first case is when we have data
on the local storage and the second case
is when we don't have any data on the
local stage okay in the same way we're
going to have two cases inside the total
amount okay so look at this if okay
basket dot length
is not equal to zero run this code else
we're just gonna return the thing
so by else return we mean that don't do
anything just stop the process okay
next up guys inside this curly bracket
we're gonna write let amount okay amount
is equal to we're gonna target the
basket and we're gonna map the thing
okay look at this we're gonna write
basket.map okay
so why am i actually mapping the thing
now guys let me tell you the main
reasons for mapping the thing okay the
main reason for mapping this thing i
mean mapping the basket is that look at
this so if i go back to the local
storage here yeah look at this deuces id
here and this is the item here we
already have the item okay we already
have the item but we don't have the
price
so using this id can you see this one
here what is this i o y right using this
id we're gonna go and search inside our
data js where is our data js our data js
is here using that id which is the i o y
can you see this one here
using this id we're gonna search inside
our data.js and then we're gonna grab
the price from there once we grab the
price from there we're gonna multiply
that with our item so that we can get
the total price i really really really
hope that you understood what i mean by
that now i'm gonna show you the live
sample okay so in the card yes look at
this i'm gonna come here and then i'm
right here bracket okay i'm gonna write
i can add anything no problem but let's
keep it simple we're gonna write here a
es6 error function and then let's pass x
okay
now curly bracket now you can you can
also destructure the x how do you
destructure the x and how does it happen
look at this this is id and the item you
can separate the thing like this look
we're gonna come here and then we're
gonna write here let okay
let curly bracket equal to it's gonna be
x okay now come here and then write item
comma id okay save the thing now on the
next line guys
what we're gonna do is using this id
we're gonna search inside our
database so guys we don't have to write
anything if you recall if you go to the
uh one second guys if you go to the
generate card items
you can easily get the function here do
you see the search function here yeah
just copy the thing because it already
exists there we don't have to write it
again copy the search function then
you're gonna just close the thing now
scroll down to your um total amount
function okay just paste the thing here
like this okay so what is it actually
doing it is using the id to match
against the database
okay for an example look at this okay
one second for an example look at this i
o y thing okay it is actually getting
stored inside where is it it is actually
getting stored inside this id okay so
this search what it will do is it's
gonna search this id against the id of
the local i mean the i mean the database
okay which is actually here okay
i really really really hope that you
understood what do i mean by this line
okay next up what we're gonna do is
we're gonna return look at this we're
gonna return the item okay by the way
let me actually show you what the item
means okay so if you go back to the
local storage here this is item here two
two three yeah that's the item and then
we have something called search dot
price look at this so you just multiply
the thing like this okay multiply search
dot price this price is actually coming
from here you see this one here okay so
now look at this guys i'm gonna
console.log the thing so that you can
see it better okay so in order to
console the thing look at this i'm right
here console okay dot log
sorry guys not here cut the thing from
here and this is else statement before
the l statement here okay paste the
thing bracket and then this is amount
here yeah copy the amount put it here
like this save the thing now guys let's
look at the result okay by the way guys
it will actually not work because you
have to invoke it so copy the thing
scroll down and put it here like this
okay bracket done save the thing let's
look at the result guys now let's go to
the console can you see this one here
200 600
775 so how is this coming this is
actually the ca actually this is
actually the calculation of these ones
can you see this one here the 600 is
here the 600 is here 75 75 200 200 okay
so we got all the all the total prices
of individual cards inside this array
here do you know what i'm gonna do next
i'm gonna add all the numbers together
in order to do that what you're gonna do
is do you see this here yeah remove the
semicolon and put a dot okay we're gonna
use the reduce function okay reduce then
you're gonna write a bracket you're
gonna take es6 error function okay
something like this then you're gonna
write here x comma y okay
next up guys you add the x and y what
does the x and y means let me tell you
the x is the
the x guys is that previous number and y
is the next number so what it's doing is
by x and y i mean that add these two
numbers and then get the next one
so that's why i wrote here x comma y and
then i have to write here x plus y and
then comma i want the thing to start
from zero that's why i'm gonna give it a
zero here okay save the thing now guys
let's look at the result there we go can
you see this one here it gave us the
calculation the total calculation that
we we're searching for so guys our
function is complete now we're going to
implement that so that it looks
something like this okay in order to
make something like this let's go back
to our vs code
let's guys uh do you see this one here
either comment or remove the thing okay
i'm going to comment a thing and then
i'm going to scroll to the very top here
this is label here yeah copy the thing
let's scroll down um to your total
amount function below this comment here
paste the thing okay then you're gonna
write it dot inner html equal to we're
gonna use a template literal so you're
gonna hit backtick and here you're gonna
write then here you can write h2 tab
okay then guys you can write here total
okay bill
colon you're gonna dollar sign for the
currency and then you're gonna write
dollar sign curly bracket amount okay
this amount is actually coming from here
you see this one here save the thing
guys now guys let's look at the result
okay
there we go we got it we have the total
build here can you see this one here
brilliant guys next up what we're gonna
do is we're gonna have two buttons one
second guys this is checkout and the
clear card button yeah we're gonna build
these two buttons here inside here so
let's go and make those things so what
you're gonna do is below the h2 tag
you're gonna make a button okay look at
this vott o n okay button with a class
name checker look at this dot c h e c k
o u t checkout tab guys guys it's gonna
be class not class name so remove the
name from here only keep the class okay
now inside here we're gonna write
checkout okay c-h-e-c-k or ut checkout
done save the thing and below this
button we're gonna have another button
with the class name remove all look at
this b-u-t-o-n
dot remove
all okay tab
now again guys it's gonna be class not
class name remove the name from here
save the thing and uh also we need to
write here clear
card something like this save the thing
let's look at the result guys it should
look something like this it is not
styled let's style the thing okay first
of all guys copy the checkout from here
now guys you're gonna go to your style
css and now guys you're gonna select for
a specific selector that we already
selected and we already built that okay
so let me just search for the thing
it's actually the home button guys can
you see this one here yeah so you don't
have to write all these styles do this
guys follow along with me just put a
comma here okay and then dot paste done
now guys let's look at the result it
should look something like this can you
see that yeah in the same way we're
gonna style the clear card button as
well follow along with me guys come back
here on your card just copy the remove
all come back to your style css comma
okay and then dot paste done save the
thing let's look at the result there we
go you see much better but guys i want
the thing to be in green color just like
this one and i want the thing to be red
color so in order to do those things
follow along with me copy the check out
okay scroll down and put it here like
this dot paste curly bracket you can
write here uh bgc tab it's going to be
which color green like this save the
thing and remove all right copy the
thing scroll down put dot paste curly
bracket uh color oh sorry bgc
tab is gonna be red there we go save the
thing now let's look at the result okay
there we go guys it looks just like our
finalized project here can i see this
one here it looks totally identical next
up guys
guys it looks nice but look at this
here's a problem every time you click on
the plus look at this this number i mean
this quantity and the price actually
increases but can you see this one here
it is not updating itself so guys in
order to update this thing i mean this
one it's very simple the solution is
very simple guys just come over here and
to your card yes do you remember the
total amount copy this thing okay
and then guys where's your update
function one second let me just fold the
thing like this where is your update
function it's actually here can you see
this one here just open the thing and
then below the calculation function you
just invoke the thing here like this
there we go done okay
now guys let's look at the result okay
every time uh this is the result page
okay every time you click on the plus
like this look at that it's updating
itself live it is working perfectly fine
okay brilliant now guys here's actually
another issue here look at this this is
29 here yeah 2900 actually just 100
every time i click on the cross like
this that's going away but it's not
actually upgrading itself there was a
hundred dollars there but now it should
be 2800 but it's not updating itself
automatically every time you hit the
refresh like this only then it refreshes
i mean only then it updates updates
itself this is the behavior that we
don't want in order to fix that where is
the function that removes that item
it is actually remove item right so copy
this one i mean copy the entire thing
open up this one and do you see this one
generate card items below this one
invoke it like this save the thing let's
look at the result okay so look at this
how much is this 1500 okay 2800 every
time you click on the cross it goes away
at the same time it updates the thing
here as well so guys it's working
perfectly fine
now guys let's go back to the home page
let's select some data okay i mean let's
select some products from here let's go
back to the cart page here
the next feature that i'm gonna build is
the clear cart feature okay every time
we click on this one it's gonna first of
all remove the entire thing at the same
time do you see this local storage guys
one second on the local storage we also
want the entire thing to get removed as
well so in order to build that follow
along with me guys come back to your
card js okay at uh below the remove item
or anywhere okay you can write the
function anywhere you like we're gonna
write here clear card okay let clear
card okay it's gonna be an es6 error
function like this okay
next up guys look at this we're gonna
write here basket equal to we're gonna
make an empty array it means that
whatever data we have on the basket
remove the thing okay
so guys once we're done removing all the
items from the basket we also need to
re-render the cards in order to
re-render the screen this is generate
card items here copy the thing scroll
down and put it here like this okay done
next up guys we also need to update the
local storage as well so in order to
update the local storage just open the
decrement or the increment like this
okay do you see this one here yeah just
copy the thing from here
uh close the thing scroll down
on the clear card okay paste the thing
here like this okay save the thing now
guys we need to invoke the clear card as
well copy the thing scroll down use this
total amount here open it okay so
where's your uh remove all it is here
can you see this over here this is a
clear card button
so guys what we're gonna do is we're
gonna right here on click okay on click
equal to double quote then we're gonna
invoke the clear cut function here there
we go save the thing guys now let's guys
let's go and test our result this is the
result screen every time you click on
one second let me also open the local
storage here like this so we have some
data on the local storage we have some
uh build here and we have some cards
here okay every time we click on the
clear card it's gonna remove everything
look at that the data is gone and the
cart i mean and the card page is gone
along with the price and the buttons we
have only one button back to home button
using this one we can just go back and
we can select some products like this
there we go let's select some products
here let's go back to our
cart page and now let's go and select
this one like this look at that it's
working perfectly fine okay let's click
on the cross sign like this it's
removing that thing at the same time if
you click on the clear cut it remove
everything like that brilliant
on the finalized project you can see
that we have in total 12 product cards
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add the other images and data into
our project here
but before doing that we have some
problem with our code here which we need
to fix the first problem is with the nav
bar it is not aligned properly on the
y-axis let me show you what i mean by
that okay so i'm just gonna go back to
the code on the style css and then what
i'm gonna do is this is nav bar here i'm
just going to comment this code okay i'm
going to save it now let's look at the
result okay can you see that the
clothing store and the icon they are not
aligned on the y axis on the center so
if you want to fix that you're just
going to come here and then you're going
to write a ic tab okay save the thing
now let's look at the result can you see
that now it's aligned properly okay so
i'm gonna bring this code back save it
there we go the second problem is in the
cart page but before going there first
of all make sure that you have some
product selected here and then you're
gonna go to the cart page okay now this
is number here how many quantity do we
have on the basket in roll we have 24
and now let's do this okay so i'm gonna
remove this one okay
so how much quantity is in this inside
this card
it has just five okay so it is 24 if i
minus 5 from 24 how much is it it's
gonna be 19 so let's remove the thing
okay every time i remove it it should be
19 but it's not doing the subtraction
it's gonna do the subtraction every time
i refresh the page like that there we go
but this is the behavior that we don't
want so if you want to fix that where is
this problem situated let's find that
first okay the problem is with the
function named remove item let me show
you where it is so what you're going to
do is you're going to go to vs code and
then you're going to go to card.js then
here is your function remove item you're
going to open up this one
and then you're going to scroll up this
is calculation function here just copy
the thing and then put it here like this
okay save the thing now let's look at
the result okay so now what we're gonna
do is we're gonna remove this one okay
how much quantity is here is five so how
much is here 19 so 19 minus five it
should be 14. let's click on this one
let's see the result okay there we go
it's working perfectly fine so our
problem is solved let's look at the
third problem it is here on the clear
card every time i click on this one what
do i want i want the basket to get zero
it but it doesn't happen let me show you
what i mean by that okay so i'm gonna
click on clear card now look at that
it's still 14 but it should be zero if i
refresh the thing only then it's gonna
be zero so guys the problem is situated
in a function named clear card let's go
find it and fix that okay so i'm gonna
go back to vs code and it is called
clear card it is here
do you remember this one calculation
just copy the thing and put it here like
this okay save it now let's look at the
result okay so in order to look at the
result we have to go back to home and
then we have to select some items okay
just like this now let's go back how
many items can you see here it's a let's
click on clear card there we go it's now
back to zero perfect problem solved all
right guys now let's go back to our vs
code and then scroll to the very top do
you remember this function here generate
card items open up this one and then do
you see this search dot image search dot
name and search dot price what i
realized is that you can destructure
this thing and make it shorter let me
show you what i mean by that okay so i'm
gonna come here and then i'm gonna write
here let curly bracket hi
image comma name comma and what was the
last thing is price so i'm gonna put the
price here like this equal to the search
okay copy that put it here like this
there we go now we don't have to write
search dot image anymore okay we can
remove that portion from here like this
okay
there we go done save the thing now
let's look at the result we're gonna get
the exact same result okay to see the
result let me just click some um
products from here and then let's go to
the cart page like that there we go you
see there we go you see we got the exact
same results and by the way guys what is
this called the search is an object
right so this is called destructuring an
object
all right guys now it's time to add the
other product cards inside our project
before doing anything first of all we
have to clear the local storage okay
just right click inspect and then you're
gonna go to your application wait a
second uh let me open up this one we're
gonna go to application then local
storage okay so now we have to delete it
so you're gonna click on here and then
you're gonna delete the thing okay next
up i'm gonna go to my github i'm gonna
provide the link of this github
repository in the description down below
okay so if you come here then you can
realize that it has three branches we
are on the main branch on the main
branch we have the entire source code
okay we started from the starter files
and this is product images here i'm
gonna click on this branch here and then
what does this branch carry let me show
you inside the images it got all the
other 12 images okay so if i come back
here we have also something called
data.js if i open up this one then it
carries all the data of our product
cards so do you see this data here yeah
all the data are actually inside this
data js so what we're gonna do right now
is we're gonna download this thing okay
so just click on the code download zip
okay
so guys once it downloads open the thing
and then you're gonna go back to your
desktop okay
then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna extract it outside like this okay
next up go inside here so what do we
have inside there we just have a folder
and a file called data.js okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna extract it
outside like this okay there we go all
right guys so now we're gonna extract
both the images and the data inside our
project folder like this look at that
okay then guys you're gonna find a
message like this replace the files in
destinations so you're gonna click ok
like this so what it's gonna do is it's
gonna remove the duplicate files from
our project now we can delete this one
no problem now let's go back to our vs
code okay now you can realize that we
have images how many images are here 12
images okay and then we also have a file
called datajs so come here and what
you're going to do is look at this do
you see this data here the data is
inside a array here you see this one
array so come here and then you're gonna
close it like this copy the entire thing
now you what you're gonna do is you're
gonna go to data.js which is actually
situated inside your source okay come
here and go to the top
select from here to the very bottom and
then paste the code that you copied from
the file okay so now look at this we
have all of our data stored inside this
variable now save the thing and now come
here and what you're gonna do is you're
gonna right click delete this one okay
this is coming from the github okay
now guys after saving the code let's go
and look at the result okay our result
will look something like this look at
that we have how many cards in total we
have 12 product cards in total but guys
there are some design problems with our
cards like look at this one this is
border here and do you see the image
they're overlapping with each other here
can you see that it looks odd we're
gonna fix that at the same time look at
this guys we don't have any gap at the
bottom just like the finalized project
look at that we have gap here so let's
go and implement those things so let's
go back to our vs code on the style css
then you're going to find that
selector with the class name shop okay
then what you're going to do is we're
going to write here mb 20 pixel tab
there we go save the thing now let's
look at the result it will look
something like this on our finalized
project but guys if you want to adjust
the gap you can do it as well so let's
come back here and you can also put here
50 pixel like this save the thing let's
look at the result now look at that we
have a big gap here
next up let's go fix the border and the
images how do you do that very simple
very easy go back to your vs code so now
you're going to find for a selector
called dot item which is actually here
can you see that we have the image
inside the selector so how do you select
the image from this selector it's very
simple look at that you can write here
dot item okay then img curly bracket
done now inside here what we're gonna
write is we're gonna write here with
hundred percent okay with hundred
percentage save the thing now let's look
at the result there we go now can you
see that the border and the image are
not overlapping with each other but guys
there's another problem if i zoom in
like this look at that can you see that
do you see this corner here yeah it's
pointy corner but actually our border is
rounded so in order to adjust that what
we're gonna do is we're going to go back
here and we're going to place a border
it is okay border radius okay radius but
before putting any value guys let me
show you something okay so we want to
make this thing rounded here and here we
don't want the thing to be rounded here
and here so how do you do this let me
show you guys so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna come back here and we're
gonna put two pixel first two pixel
again then zero zero so what do i mean
by this this is the top left corner this
is the top right corner this is the
bottom left and bottom right corner
values save the thing now let's look at
the result now guys you can see that
this thing got rounded and this one as
well but not the bottom left and the
bottom right perfect
with that our project is complete i
really really really hope that you
learned a lot from this tutorial if you
like the video give a like share with a
friend and feel free to subscribe till
then take care and i'll see you in the
next video